Oh,
sweetness.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
and entering the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the
number one sex toy for men.
I have used it. Our guests today, Bert
Kreischer can neither confirm nor deny,
but I did have a run in in Miami
that was seemed close to it.
I don't know what that means. Called sex
in a cam. Oh, it's the same. Same Guy,
but it looks like a beer can really, and
then there's the lips. You got to it.
Yeah. Which is not cool. You
have some dude looking back
at you. Look, come on dude.
Super Sleuth. It looks like dude's
lip, so it does to me. I mean,
it doesn't look like a chick
slips. It doesn't look very
check anyway. Right? Well,
at least the vagina,
you can guess.
Yeah.
I say I vote for,
I think to have one form of
it where it's like anonymous.
It's neither a butthole nor a
vagina is just sort of a hole,
which is probably the best move.
It's just the whole script.
No one's looking at it getting turned
on by this little circle of fake vagina.
It's like a whole,
like you're in Thailand on vacation.
So I'm talking about dog
Andrew and the code name Rogan.
You'll get 15% off the norm.
I'm trying to shorten these things
cause I drag them on forever.
We were also brought to you by on it.com
o n n I t makers of Alpha brain day is
what is today's date is um, the 28th.
This is the 28th, which is a cyber Monday.
So if you,
if you're hearing this on November 28th
and if you go to [inaudible] dot com and
enter in the code named cyber,
then you get 25% off just for today.
Tastes cyber Monday.
You ever heard of cyber Monday?
Yeah, I tried to. I tried
to buy a zoom h to Z.
Do you know I'm talking about
Brian? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'll try to buy it on cyber Monday
cause apparently black Friday last black
Friday, my dead shit, his pants on a
banana republic, he shit his pants,
his pants and a banana republic.
What happened? I was buying a jacket,
this leather jacket, and he wanted a
sweater and all of a sudden he comes up,
he's got my daughters in my head, in
his hands, and he goes, buddy, buddy,
we're about to have a problem.
What's the matter? And he goes,
I'm about to shit my pants and we're in
Beverly hills. He goes, what do we do?
What do I do? I said, I think
you just cheat your pants,
your fucking 60 years old.
You just shoot. Your band's goes, wow. I
gotta go. And he could walk. Oh my God,
it's bands in Beverly Hills. Oh my
God. Oh my God. How far is the walk?
The pretty woman hotel,
we were on the banana republic in
Beverly Hills and he walked with a pretty
woman hotel, we shit in his pants and
then got up to the house and he was like,
oh, it was bad. But it hasn't
happened in a long time.
Did his underwear contain this shit or
did that on his leg? I have no idea.
But he,
when he was in his thirties,
he used to shit his pants
all the fucking time.
Like my pants on the reg.
Like
Shit. I went a nickel for every
time. This is before cell phones.
This is too good of a story they use
up during this commercial. Oh come on.
We're in a commercial to the music
and then I need to hear about your,
your old man shit and I'm sorry.
Okay,
hear this. But we need to get this out
of the way where people go fucking crazy.
So, uh, anyway, today, cyber Monday,
we're going to get right back to your
old man and shit in the pants story.
Just people been complaining so much about
the length of these commercials and I
agree.
That's why I'm continuing to drag it out
right now.
Joe rogan.day.
Click on the link.
Every day you get 10% off it.
Click on the link for Alpha brand.
You get 10% off.
If you enter in the code name Brogan and
today and only today is the 25% sale.
We also have a new product called
new mood. And New mood is a, um,
it's a five HTP supplement.
It's also got a l trip to fan,
which your body slowly converts.
That's what I want the building blocks.
I was listening to you
and I was in New York.
That's good stuff.
Five HTP in and of itself.
And then as we say in
all of these products,
there's a hundred percent money
back guarantee. If you return,
you don't even have to return it
and just eat it. You don't like it,
you get your money back.
And if you think that the too expensive
and you're interested in nootropics,
please look it up online.
There's plenty of great articles and
great pieces written on nootropics.
And if you want just to steal our,
our ingredient list and make your
own and save some money, okay.
But if you want to buy from us,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and
today you'll get 25% off with the code
word cyber. Alright, you dirty bitches,
bird crisis in the house,
the fucking machine.
Last return trying my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Yeah,
in our long drawn out commercials that
I do to sponsor this podcast to keep it
free,
ladies and gentlemen,
because otherwise it would be unbearable
if we couldn't make money from this
fucker.
Um,
w Burke Chrysler was telling what I
smell might be one of the great stories.
No, his dad. No, he used to shit his
pants all the time. All the time.
How long would you said the story began
with you saying that he shit his pants
in a banana republic in
Beverly Hills and uh,
it was, it was like real, it was like,
like the real coming of age part of my
life when my dad looked at me and he was
like, buddy, I'm about to shit my pants.
What do I do? We, here's the word,
here's where public have a
bathroom. Here's the fucking
horse part of it, right?
So I look at him and I go to shit,
your pants dad,
I think you shit your pants and I go,
Shit your pants a little bit and then
walk as far as you can and get to your
hotel.
And he just left.
My daughter's with me like fucking drop
them and was like, I'm talking out.
And so he started walking down
Rodeo or whatever, you know, Burton,
one of those roads to get to his hotel,
right? So my mom comes up and she's like,
she's like, where's your dad? And I
said, oh, he left me this sweater,
I got to buy it for, I bought them, ended
up buying them the sweater and I go,
he had he shit his pants. She goes, what
do you mean he had he shit his pants.
I go, we had to, she had to shit. So
he shit his pants and then he just,
he's walking down the street. I
go, I'm sure we can catch him.
He's walking slow and then my wife comes
up, she goes, where's your dad? And I go,
he shit his pants. He goes, why didn't
you just use the bathroom? I said,
where's the bathroom? She goes
downstairs and I went, Ooh,
I probably should have told them that
and so you didn't think you were in the
past? I don't know. I was in panic mode.
It was black Friday and I'm waiting in
line too when I got a leather jacket on
sale.
Well,
it's even worse.
I think if you shit your pants in line
for the bathroom because then everybody's
going to know.
If there's a big line of people that
you just blow is dumping your pants,
then you like close proximity.
There's no way to
play off shitting your pants
when you shit your pants.
I say that shit in your pants
is a lot like getting a Dui.
You roll the dice so much and get away
with it that when you do get caught with
your hand and cookie jar,
you're like,
mother fucker just never thought that
was going to happen. Are you kidding me?
Why? I do this all the time.
Why today? Oh, that's so true.
When his thirties, he was running
marathons and he used his shit,
his pants all the time. Not even
like, I'm not even saying like,
I'm not even saying like, oh, uh,
once a month, I'm talking once a week.
He would, this is before cell phones
too. He lives in his thirties.
He was in his thirties. I was a,
I was a kid. We were living in,
in like North Tampa and not
in like the nicer north Tampa,
but in the Shittier redneck
verse, Black North Tampa. And uh,
first time I ever heard her,
the n word was in this neighborhood,
but my dad used to run marathons
so we'd run like five miles,
10 miles and he'd go out and on these
10 mile runs, he shit his pants.
So he go into these orange
groves, shit himself, right.
Clean himself the best he could and then
run home. But there were some nights,
I remember these distinctly, it was
before cell phones where it get dark.
And my was like,
we got to go look for your dad.
And we'd be driving his
route where he'd run it.
All of a sudden like a naked happy.
My Dad would come out of the
fucking orange groves like I'm here,
give me in the car right now. If he knew
who he come get him. Oh, he just would.
Yeah,
it would be.
I remember thunder and lightening and he's
just sitting in an orange grove naked,
like how did it shit his pants and, and
we'd be like over here and he'd be like,
all right, you just hop in the front
seat, go home, let's go real quick.
He shit his pants. He hates
my stories. I hope someone,
if anyone is listening to this,
knows my dad.
Let him listen to this because every
fucking story I ever tell he fucking Oise
goes, God damn, you're fucking
imagination. Not how it fuck.
I did not shit my pants. I Shit
a little bit. I didn't Shit My,
you're making people digging shit
in my pants. He just squirts.
He's just a little squirt her, I dunno.
Let's call him on the phone. Do it.
Let's get my dad on the phone.
See this is a perfect example of my dad
and I are night and day human beings.
We were telling stories this
weekend about like, like one time,
one time, one morning I thought I
was, my parents were out of town,
my little sister was 10, I was probably
21 I was drinking a lot at the time.
So it was you know, party,
Animal Shit. And then,
and I was pissing a lot of places that
like in the round houses, like a pistol.
My ex girlfriend's dining room
table and was walked in by her dad.
Do you want to talk about a fucking
nightmare? Only waiting. Waiting, waiting.
Wait a minute.
You pissed on the dining room?
MEDOC her dad walked
in and caught her dad.
Larry MEDOC in Orlando. Larry,
if you're listening, I, I,
I'm guilty.
I so here's,
okay cause I never really
accepted blame for it.
I always said it never
fucking happened cause it,
cause I didn't want it to cause I
didn't want, okay. Why did you do it?
It was thanksgiving. It was right after
the rolling stone magazine came out.
And so,
and I go back to party on what do you
mean the rolling Stone magazine with a
number of the rolling stone in 1997 called
me the number one party animal in the
country just for someone
who's not, doesn't know. And
then that was a big deal.
I became famous and I became famous
in like Tampa, Florida, Tampa,
Tallahassee, Gainesville, Orlando.
Anywhere that I had people with four
went to Florida state lived. I was,
they knew who I was. They were
like, cause the fucking party guy.
So if I went out shots, really we'd
any do people put drugs in my hand.
Like it was fucking insane. I get roof
feed. I got referred a couple of times.
So you became like a sort
of celebrity partier.
I became the guy that I'd walk after the,
before the article I was just the loud,
fun, shirtless guy on top of the
bar, getting everyone in a frenzy.
And then when the article came out it was
like the fucking lineman would come to
the bar. I drank at Yonnie's and
they'd pull me aside and they're like,
you're drinking with us tonight.
We want to drink with a party animal and
then I just be up with these lines and
like four lineman and we'd be just doing
shots and shots and shots and these
guys are 350 pounds,
two to 18 at the time,
probably like going through to 18
and probably more like two 25 but,
but and so I became like,
like I say famous,
I say like reality show famous like
the way Snookie her first season was,
you know, so that's how you were in
your town and you're in Tallahassee.
If I went and read right after that
article came out in Tallahassee,
definitely in Orlando, I knew 40%
of the bar knew who I was in Tampa.
Everyone knew who I was back when
people actually read magazines that it's
before reality shows. Before the Internet,
before the Internet is a big one.
It's like you were in this,
so like you were,
I was on Oprah called and
wanted me to be on her show,
but she wanted my parents to be on two
and I was like, I'm not gonna do that.
And My fucking parents.
So I did everything I did like
fucking they sent you ready for this?
This is how bizarre this eight
period period got, they sent ESPN,
sent a tour bus with two actors in it
to come shoot a commercial of partying
with me of what it's like to party with
a number one party animal for the x
games. Right. They wanted to like the, and
one of the actors was Johnny Knoxville,
fucking bizarre shit. So Johnny Knoxville,
we meet and he says, you do drugs.
And I was like, I was like, in my head,
I'm like, yeah, I'm an adult. Let's do it.
So going to this tour bus,
I had never done pills like
pills and so he like pores,
I click send on Shit.
No, no. Little stronger.
Probably like Pete title pom probably
still, he's just poured some tea,
some Tylenol's, whatever it
was. He pours him in my hand.
And so I like thumb one finger,
one hold it down and he gives me too when
I pop one and then he starts passing a
bow. So you're being calculated
about it. I was like,
I don't know what the fuck I'm taking.
I have no idea.
And I haven't started drinking. I haven't
done like, I'm just like, what the fuck?
And there's not like someone might not
got dive a fucking overdose around that
guy. Yes, but he, this was before jackass,
right? This is, this is like five,
10 years before jackass.
And those were wild dunes.
And Johnny Knoxville is passing bills
around and he's lightened a bong and we're
doing bong hits and he's,
you gotta be careful of that and videos
he's putting in videos of, of, of uh,
of Bam. Margera trying to bring a bottle
over his head and he's like, watch this.
And I were laughing our tits off.
This is well before anyone
knows what the fuck this is.
And then I look at the other guy, I forget
the other name, but I go, what was that?
And he was like, dilaudid, you never had
dilauded go. It's dilaudid. And he's like,
it's like pharmaceutical heroin.
It's awesome. You're gonna love it.
And I was like, thank God I only took
one. Jesus Christ. That's like what?
Like they used to give chicks
in the wild west movies. Yeah.
When they had an issue. I have, she needs
some dilaudid was a little dilauded.
So we end up partying all night. We take
this tour bus out, fill it up, dresses,
women, throw herself down the stairs
that says women fucking the corner.
The craziest nights over that drinking
and beer bottles over our heads.
It was the craziest fucking night of
my life. Cut. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. So, um, there were no, they were,
they were a fake breakaway beer bottles.
But we were like, but we had seen Bam
do it and we thought it was funny.
So we were doing it with
these fake breakaway bottles,
but we're hit it with a real bottle. Bam.
And I think it was Bam. In his posse,
but it was a CKY posse. They were trying
to break a beer bottle over their head.
How did that happen? That that
became my genre of entertainment.
Like the Jackass Watch. Dude's do
fucked up things and get hurt. Well,
what happened? I have no
idea. I don't know, but I've
made a living doing it start.
It started off with like Charlie
Chaplin falling down the stairs,
like the Buster Keaton pro,
like physical comedy.
Like I didn't see jackass three but I
laughed my ass off at the fucking trailer.
I just, Oh, there's a bunch of movies and
I just haven't gotten around to seeing,
and that's one of them.
But when that guy walks in the door and
the giant hand fucking clobbered him
with the face and he goes flying, I'm
sorry. That's hilarious. It's a great,
it's fucking hilarious. It's
great. And it's funnier than,
I'm 39 years old with two kids and
it still makes me laugh. My Dad's,
it's like an advanced version of like
that Charlie Chaplin Shit, right? Oh yeah,
that's exactly what it is. The
thing is, it's guys, it's buddies.
They're all in it together.
Retard shit playing.
When Johnny Knoxville put
a fucking blindfold on and
stood in front of the bull,
he's out of his fucking mind. And this
is after he's already a movie star,
doesn't need to do it.
And that was one upping them.
So they had to do it and you're just like,
this guy says fuck.
He was doing movies with the Rock and yet
he would put a blindfold on a stand in
front of a fucking real bull. A
real bulls. Oh, that was terrifying.
And the way he got launched easily could,
a horn could, could've gone through him.
Oh, I got mauled by a bowl and
I'll tell you right now. Yeah,
I got my bible and heard Burt.
It was, yeah, this is before
you're riding it. No, no,
no. I was a Rodeo clown. They just go,
they just taught me how to put the
makeup on. They're like, all right,
you're ready. I go, hold on. I'm gonna
learn anything. And they're like, oh,
stay away from the bowl. And I was like,
that's it. And then they pull the pin.
You hear that?
Or the gate opens and a real fucking
bull comes at like a real book.
Jesus comes and I just,
we just met in my rib cage and he broke
my ribs and broke my foot. Oh my God.
Yeah. And then, and then the
producer, Tim Scott says,
you say Tim Scott with a little bit
of them and you're going to fucking,
I love the guy, but he did a
cock sucker says to me, uh,
that was really good. That's really
good footage. We're going to do it.
We need to do it like two more times.
Hold on. You're out of your fucking mind.
After you got your rib broke you
five broken ribs and a broken foot.
And I'm sitting on the ground wind
knocked out of me just eh, and he's,
well it's only
like eight seconds of
footage. Like whoa. He goes,
we need it to be a segment and in segments
three and a half minutes and we can't
make a footage out of
eight, three, eight seconds.
I mean if you watch it online it's
they just reap, cause I didn't,
wouldn't do it again and they just
replay it over and over and over.
Pretty uncreative of him that you couldn't
come up with some sort of a way to
fill that time where you would talk over
it and describe what a terrible idea it
was. Yeah, that's what we ended up doing.
Believed that he was so irresponsible.
They would ask you to do it again.
It's Tim Scott for you.
Why were you willing to do it
the first place? I love Tim.
He's still a friend of mine, but
because I was, I don't know Tim,
I don't know it was, but he sounds
like a douche bag now. He's, he's,
he's in the Philippines right now.
He's not listening to me this good so,
but I'm sure he's a nice guy. But to
ask you to do that after your ribbon,
your foot is crazy. It was also, it
was like a, I don't know, we told him,
talked about this a couple of times.
It was like a new discovery of of there.
This is me getting mauled by the ball
right here. So that's the book, right?
That's not a baby bull at all. And
that's me. Now if you're on the clock,
you're probably looking at like right
now it's four seconds and they're cutting
this up to make it look longer.
But this is exactly how quick it took.
Just the bull comes and they go,
all right, this is the [inaudible].
And then right now I'm trying to run,
but my foot's broken so I can't
stand on it. Oh my God, Dude.
Like you got hit by a truck. Yeah,
I got hit by a fucking truck.
Backed down just a little bit. Just
the impact. Let it play for a second.
It'll start. Yeah, replace
it itself. I mean it'll,
it'll replay it. Yeah, no, back
up a little bit more, Brian.
So we can see the impact.
Oh,
this is the first shot of the day. This
is, we haven't shot anything right now.
All we've done is we shot me put
on makeup that weighs nothing way.
It's gotta be 800 pounds. That's it.
Fucking, I dunno. I Dunno. I guess.
I don't think that's
he's going to be sued.
I think that's a lot bigger than that.
Oh my God, that thing nailed you.
It Hits me Square. I've never been hit
that solid by anything. I was just,
I said that the clip I got to hit
them mouth with a baseball bat.
I've been hit by cars. I've been
hit like in a car accident. But man,
when that bowl,
it's whole head connected with my whole,
and we met where my mic was right now.
Um, this is after, this is me going,
I'm not fucking doing it again. Look, I'm
pretty face too much. I was skinny. I was,
oh my God does show it like nailed. Oh
my God, look at that impact. I know.
Holy Shit. And you're lucky.
The thing that stumped on
your head. Wait, watch, watch.
You can see where it breaks my foot.
It doesn't look like those,
those look, watch it right. Here you go.
That's the hope print.
God,
just get this boy away from me so that I
don't speak with a slur for the rest of
my life. And have it in my head. I do
more cushioning in your face.
It's filtered from your beer
checked.
You are right where you should
have been charged for first time.
How many times these guys would hit.
These are professional. This guy fucking,
he was, he was cut like
all stitches. Broken bones.
What a crazy way to make a living. Right.
I don't know how he's, Oh we, okay.
So wait, I'm going to bring it
back to where we started. So,
so that is my connection with Jack Ass
and that I didn't show very similar to it
for six episodes.
We did six episodes,
but I met Johnny Knoxville
after the rolling stone stuff.
The rolling stone stuff was crazy when
that came out it was like being famous
cut back to how I pissed on my
girlfriend's table. So thank you.
So that was like unwinding. I was like,
that was like untangling a necklace.
Is that so and so we go out in Orlando,
this is right after Thanksgiving
when everyone's home.
So everyone I know from
Orlando is at every bar.
All in like Church Street I
think is the name of the street.
So we go out and it's fucking
chaos on with my girlfriend,
her sister and her sister's boyfriend
who was the coolest fucking guy and he'll
always have weed. So we go out
and everyone's buying me shots.
We're getting fucking hammered.
Her parents had just bought a house,
just bought this brand new house just
like I ended. It was their dream house.
We had Thanksgiving together. We held
hands, talked about how at the table,
how this is everything we've worked
for guys as a team. We saved,
we scrimped we buy. Anyway, we go
back to her house and I'm like,
I'm not fucking done. Like I want to keep
drinking. And this Guy Dan, he's like,
oh yeah,
me too.
So we got like a 12 pack of beer and
we'd go out to the dock and d and that's
all I remember Danny.
Then the next morning we counts
everything to me because I might,
she walks in the first
thing in the morning,
could you piss on my dining
room table? And I'm like, no.
Why would I fucking do that? I'm a
grown man. I don't piss on tables.
You'd like my dad said he
caught you pissing on her table.
Make your dad is crazy.
He doesn't like me cause I'm in the party
animal and he's trying to get me out
of your life.
That's what's fucking going on.
And you got the fucking room for
going to blame it on me. Shit,
I'm the party animal. I'm sure. I'm sure
you know what the fuck you're talking to
right now. He wants me out of your life.
Number one party animal. The
country, but something to the, yeah,
I'm sure I actually use the words so
you probably had to Kesha explaining it.
Aw. Did you ever think about getting it?
I'm the party animal tattooed
anywhere in your body.
I was thinking about getting a squirrel
with a beer can in a cigarette that said
the parties squirrel on at one time.
Who's going to fuck a question that too
so we can tell me what your tattoo about
it.
If I was a cop and I pulled you over and
you had a party squirreled Tatooine I'd
immediately take you to jail.
I'm like,
I know this guy did something fucked
up in the last couple of months.
You've just got to get it out of them.
We just going to sit down and go,
you know what you did? Just tell me
you know what you did. Just tell me.
We'll all get out of here early.
We'll get you a nice quick sentence.
Just tell me what happened so I don't
even know what you're talking about. Okay,
so, so she, I party, Squirrel foot.
She goes out to the breakfast
table where family is. Oh my God.
How much pissed are we talking about here?
In my head it didn't happen.
And your head, it didn't happen. You
didn't have any black out fucking,
I swear to you, all my children
right now, I laid in that bed,
rolled over and I went, how?
Fuck, wait a minute. How do you,
how do you know your home?
He didn't fucking sell you down the river.
Maybe he pissed on a table
and then say that you did it.
That's why he woke you up in the morning.
He knew you blacked out and then they
blame you for pissing on the table.
That's what's going through my head
right now is I rolled back over and I go
fuck them. Maybe, maybe, maybe
that would be called shitting,
but yet maybe we call
it a Brian train wreck.
You smoking a regular cigarette
over there? No, it's got
wheat in it. All right, so,
so Danny,
the boyfriend comes in and he's like,
comes in and his eyes are like so excited.
He goes,
I heard you piss on their
table. And I'm like, no,
why is everyone fucking saying that?
And he's like,
cause her dad walked in on your
pissing on the table and I said,
he's fucking lying. He goes,
man, he is pretty set in the,
he saw you pissing on their dining
room table. And I go, Danny,
I don't remember fucking anything. He
goes, he goes, well we got these beers.
We went out to their doc, do remember
that? And I go, yes. And he was like,
and I had a joint. And I go, okay,
I remember that. And he's like,
and then you ate the joint. And I was
like, I don't remember that. And he goes,
yeah, I said, hold this
and you ate it and laughed.
And then we killed all the beers out there
and I go, fuck, we did. And he was like,
yeah. And then you start piecing
back like little things. I go,
did we get stuck in a phone booth
last night? And he's like, no,
we got locked in their food cabinet,
like in their, in their food closet,
like a pantry in their pantry because
we were eating in their kitchen.
And then this and this. I start, remember
I go, yeah, so like a girlfriend,
the girlfriend's coming in, it
was a sliding door. So it was,
we were eating and the girlfriends
came out, the sisters and they go,
you're fucking making a ton of noise.
So me and Danny went into
the pantry and shut the door.
But then we couldn't figure out how to
open it because there wasn't a handle.
You guys were hammered and you had a
pantry may shoved you in the Pantry to
quiet you down.
We shoved ourselves into the pantry so
that we can continue eating. We're like,
we're going to bed. They left, we
went to the Pantry, shut the door,
and then I remember sitting in the pantry.
I do remember this distinctly is us being
in the pantry thinking we in a phone
booth laughing how hard all,
they had all this food in this
phone booth and we're like,
he believed this bull Moose
heads fucking Doritos in it.
So then that's all I remember.
So then he says to me,
he goes,
them man, he's really adamant. So he
leaves. I lay back down and I'm like,
I can't believe I'm in frame for
this shit. All of a sudden I start.
You ever have one of those where you
remember the dream you had last night?
And I distinctly remember seeing her dad
in his underwear. In my dream, I'm like,
I'm like, wait. I did have a dream about
her dad and his underwear. That's odd.
And then I was like,
but he was in here yelling at me.
There's not a jury and you had sex with
an old man. No, he, what happened was,
and this, and then I start going,
oh shit, this totally did happen.
I woke up in the middle of the night,
walked out to their dining room table,
erect and tried to go to the bathroom.
You know how you would kind
of try to lean it down.
So I must've been making a ton of
noise at their dining room table.
Pissed on their dining room table, full
blown, pissed on their dining room,
whatever. This now, now I'm
remembering. I'm like, Oh shit,
I fucking do remember you. I remember
being erect. I remember, yeah, I remember.
I remember, I just remember trying
to pee. You know how when you,
you have one of those nights where you're
like in the bathroom and you're like,
I can't get to like lean forward.
So I'm leaning forward over their
dining room table, trying to Piss,
making a ton of noise, knocking everything
off of it. He comes out and is tidy.
Whities I remember that because she came
back in and I go to is your dad were
tidy? Whities and she goes, he does.
Why I don't want it. Nevermind.
I mean you can't dream. I like,
no one wears off. So anyhow,
I dream about tighty whities twenties
let's say 26 25 so here's the worst part.
He yells at me and he goes, where the
fuck? What the fuck are you doing?
And I said, I'm going to bed. And
he said, where's your bed? And I,
and I pointed to the dining room table.
I go right here. And he goes, what? I,
David Blaine the tablecloth,
pull it, lay on the bed on the,
on top of their table at the table.
He pissed him in my own business and my
this in a superman, cape full of Piss.
Just let Kurt and myself go back to sleep
and he gets me up and walks me into my
bed and puts me back in my bed.
And I'm like,
what a nice guy. We it with, our
relationship was fucking doomed.
Like there was no,
I get up that he's a nice guy.
He's a really nice Larry Maddock is a
saint because if that happened to one of
my daughters and my house, I would have
beat the fucking kid's ass. So I get up.
What'd you really man? No,
do it like that again though.
I would beat the fucking
kids as passionate voice.
Have you ever considered
acting? Maybe, maybe Ip.
All the time when I'm really wasted.
Like if I black out like drunk night,
I'll wake up and think like,
Oh I have to pee right now.
And I always like put on a
shirt the next morning like, oh,
why is it smelled like urine?
All that did it again. I've done,
I do it all the time when I drink a lot.
So when you a lot, you'll piss the bed.
I think I get confused and
I wake up and I'm like,
I just pee on my suitcases lie.
Like if I put in hampers
hammered of really drunk
people. Peanut suitcases. Yeah.
That's actually fairly common.
Yeah, it happens maybe twice a year,
but it's still happens enough where I'm
just like ever do something like that.
Ready?
Never did something like that.
That sounds like something right up
Eddie Bravo. He probably peed on the,
Eddie used to have these
blackouts that were so bad.
I had to write a story about it.
I wrote a blog entry called drug Eddie.
I think I read that it was that about
when you guys were in Rome and he missed
his flight. Germany, Germany. Well,
he didn't miss his flight. He took my,
my car to the airport.
He was so hammered and he woke
up in the backseat of the car,
didn't know anything. I go downstairs,
I'm like, where's there's a car?
It's supposed to be to take me to the
airport for Rogan and they go rogue and
already left and I go, what?
He goes, yeah, long hair,
tattoos like mother fucker.
So I called Joe Rogan airports
like an hour and a half away.
He's only five minutes away
from it by the time I call him,
like the car is already there
and I'm like, what happened
man? What are you doing?
He said, I don't know. I woke up in
the back of this car. To be fair.
He was wearing Joe's clothes.
He was wearing an outfit that
looked the resembled me. No,
it was um,
just a,
a party time and I just got got
hammered and some man, they just,
they, they just can actually
forget what happened.
Oh yeah, I've definitely blacked out. I
don't drink like that anymore. I haven't,
I have not had an episode like
that in a really long time.
Like in years ago,
you and I stopped doing it
or just the last few days,
like four days I stopped
drinking caffeine. I needed
to cut it all out. I'm dude,
I've never done that ever. Like
consciously cut it out. But I'm like,
I love coffee. I like the smell of
it. I like the ritual of it. I, I,
I make French press coffee, so I
grind the beans and I, you know,
nice water. You know, I use clean
filtered water and I, you know,
I get this Kona coffee beans for
Hawaii. It's delicious. It tastes good,
but you know, it's, you,
you get these spikes and then the crash
is that the really fucked up thing.
And the last couple of days I've
had no caffeine like the last five,
six days and there's no
crash. It's weird. It's like,
just scream. Anything else? Do you find
yourself eating tons of chocolate? No,
but I want to drink the coffee and
it's not that I need it, it's that.
It's a ritual. It's a, it's etched
in my mind. Like, you know, Oh,
I'm at Barnes and noble by an emagazine.
Let me just get a cup of coffee and say,
I gotta take a shit.
I gotta take a shit at Barnes and
noble has some of the worst shits ever.
You walk into that bathroom, if
you have to pig, God bless you.
God bless you in your nostrils.
Smell some coffee shits.
But to me with just eaten those
fucking cookies and drinking coffee,
I can't, I can't. Here's my problem with
coffee. Here's why I want to cut it.
Cut it out. Because I had my first
cup and I feel really good. Then I go,
let's have another card.
Let's have another cop.
So I have my other cop and then I'm
like, man, I'm fucking tweaking.
I need to write. You need to get
some shit, laundry. And then,
and then I had my third cup and now
my eyes are twitching and I'm like,
I don't feel so good. I want to take,
I want to take a Xanax and go to bed.
Then I'm like, why can't I just
find a happy middle ground? Yeah,
it's good if you want to get something
done. Like it's good. I I um,
I debated back and forth whether or not
to have one right before the podcast
cause like it's always good to be charged
up. I do the podcast and I was like, no,
let's see what happens. Cause I've, I've
been doing this for the past. Like I said,
I guess it's probably been about five
or six days now and very little alcohol.
The only alcohol I've been limiting myself
to like one drink, one glass of wine,
maybe two at the most. But that's it. I
read this thing recently about drinking,
about like going out and getting fucked
up and how bad it is on your muscles and
he's off.
You do this,
you're your body's ability to recover.
And then it takes you three weeks
to get back to 100%, three weeks.
All sorts of shit that it does.
Like when you get severely dehydrated
from really getting hammered, really,
really hung over.
There's also an effect on cerebral spinal
fluid that takes two weeks to recover
from. So there's like all these different
things, the different processes that a,
that happened when your body gets severely
dehydrated and so really fucked up
from alcohol. And there's just like this
rebuilding process. It's like, you know,
it takes a long time and if you're
fucking hitting it hard all the time,
you really never given
yourself a chance to recover.
That's why pre prematurely
aged, you know. And I um,
started feeling recently that like,
like I've never taken time away from,
from coffee.
I've never taken time away from alcohol
and I've always done whatever I wanted
to do and fall and I have a couple of
years, we'll have a couple of years.
I wanted to drink wine, I drink
wine. I never thought about it.
I never really tried to limit myself.
So this is a psychological pulled
is a problem. It's like you,
you start thinking about
it and psychologically you
could see how people can get
addicted to things because psychologically
when you resist something, I could,
I went on a diet once for a little while.
I tried to Atkins Diet just for a goof,
just to see what his life fucking
diet. Yeah. It's good. Except you.
If you cut something out of your
life like pasta. Yeah, Dude.
That is the shit you're going
to crave and such a a rabbit.
Hey man, I never want cookies, but I
want as I'm Atkins, I want to cook all.
Exactly.
It's easy to eat clean if
you decide to eat clean,
but if you've got some crazy law,
like if you have some rules and now
you know you're following those,
you're not just eating clean. You know
you're following those specific rules.
All of the things that aren't on there.
The thing is you start crazy.
Yeah. It's the second
I quit drinking. I go,
that's when all the beer commercials
look awesome. Yeah. Like, man, I can't,
I can't ever quit.
I can't ever quit for good.
That's why I need to reel it in
every now and then and go, all right,
I need to be in control of everything
so it won't be a fucking alcoholic.
I don't want to be something lush.
Who who you see on stage and all he does
is slur his words and lays down on the
stage
and alcohol, commercial,
a beer commercial.
That's all you really need is just
that little push. It's like your,
what it is is you're already
thinking about getting drunk.
That alcohol commercial,
like people say that targets children and
it looks like what a great party. Yeah,
sorta.
But you know who it really targets.
It really targets guys who
aren't partying. That's
thinking about have that beer.
Maybe they broke up the black. Now I'm
only 50 and I got another shot in me. Man.
I've seen some fucking
old guys and young girls
today start thinking things like that.
But it's such a natural feeling. Normal.
It's a normal part of being a monkey.
So my dad is going through,
going through like Dad's ready to
get some young person, I dunno,
but being around the podcast,
we'll see what sucked he was he,
if there's a girl out there and there's
a million people on this podcast,
there's a girl in there that this was
never know his pants. Some girls like that
smell of urine and true.
He had a blood infection and almost died.
Whoa.
Like a couple couple, like a
week ago, two weeks ago we sent,
now you got that charity
posts coming your way.
I see what you're working is that,
that somebody puts their gum,
old shit is really in his fucking head
about almost over and then you start.
Then it got into my head and I was like,
wow man, I'm 39 like this is coming.
You're healthy dude. You enjoy the
moment. That's the most important thing,
but take care of your vehicle.
You know the real problem with fucking
alcohol is alcohol kills your vehicle.
You know the marijuana, alcohol, and
when you're costing for your world,
the body is a vehicle. Brian Red
Band, the body, the human body.
The problem is alcohol is fun as fuck.
You know,
this is the very few things like that
are as fun as just a good night out.
When you're drunk with a bunch of fun
friends and you're all laughing and
cracking up and the end of the
night you go eat somewhere stupid.
Eat some greasy meat concoction with
cheese and gravy and you and you take your
fat stupid ass to bed. And
all those nights are fun,
man. Those, those are some,
some brilliant nights. But God damn those
Sunday morning suck a bag, don't they?
They suck dude.
That,
that feeling of hung over as you're
headed to the airport and you can't drink
enough water and you're like I said,
Vegas ones.
I think the biggest ones are the worst.
Yeah,
because also you get outside of those
casinos and there's no longer oxygen
pumping everywhere.
Is that a myth?
They actually do that and there's
no clocks in any casinos. It's true.
But you don't, you ever
watch a stupid fuck? No.
Cause they didn't because my watch is my
iPhone and they scramble all the iPhone.
So none of the phones work,
so you have no phone shit.
Do you believe that you believe they
scramble the phone? Fuck yeah, I do.
I don't believe that they scramble it
100% but I believe that as soon as I walk
in there, I'll go from three to four
bars to no service back and forth.
Yeah. That just goes back and
forth almost like they're,
they're making your phone's cut off so
that you could just say to your wife,
what honey, honey, I'm, I'm by the
tables. I'll call you in and out.
No, it's, it's a good thing for that.
And they set these places up like
you get lost in them. Oh yeah.
All the carpet's fucking confusing.
Yeah. And there's a amaze. You realize
who you going through all those machines.
They're not set up in some sort of an
orderly way that's easy to see for your
space. Now there's a God damn maze.
It's like the mains of the shining.
That's exactly what it's like.
I want to get you in there and
hopefully suck everything out of you.
Suck the money out to you
either through your balls,
there's hookers and those mazes or
suck the money out to the machine.
We had a hooker one time at Vegas,
not had a hooker,
but we had a hooker proposition.
Me and my buddy Eddie and, and my,
and she was the one of the hottest
chicks I've ever seen in my life.
And my buddy Eddie was like, how
much? And she was like $1,300. I can't
cause I'm a cause I'm trying to drive
home tonight. This is good for driving.
Yeah, it's just a cigarette.
Yeah. Until I go. Wow.
My feet feel like they're glued into the
space. We'd is good for driving. This is,
this makes you think you're not even
driving anymore and driving here on the,
which Macola, I was like, felt
like I was in a video game.
It's called the highway son. Who's the
stone one? Yeah. Where's that? You know,
driving in on that.
Which McAllen in that thing don't do.
It's a new fangled hard surface.
The earth is using.
It's the thing I put the alcohol and all
those new mind vehicle. The new monkeys
transporting themselves in a much more
rapid way and it's a hard surface,
what is it called?
Whatever. Whatever. Anyway,
point being Marijuana Fox,
my driving up,
I could never, I could never drive high.
Really? How can you drive or did you do?
Why don't drive that high? I'll
be here for a few hours. I, I'm,
I'm pretty sober by the time I
actually leave, but I do Jujitsu hard.
I did a lot of things. I do comedy,
high sugar stop your buzz, but it also,
you don't have to realize I have a high
tolerance, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When you're smoking a leg.
And then my last year of college I
was smoking a lot of weed and I could,
I could smoke all night long and be fine,
but I now if I, if I took like a hit,
I definitely feel it. Especially I
think we'd was different back then too.
We'd good for you for Christ. Let me
tell you something. Don't listen to me.
I don't follow my advice because
it's faulty. I have, you know,
it's a lot of trial and error and a,
I mean quite a few errors.
I'm not saying I'm right about everything,
but I'm right about this.
We'd my friend, I'm not right
about everything, my friend
good for you. And what you are afraid
of with weed is what we all need.
We all need a little humility.
We all need to be terrified by the Matrix.
We all need a view of the great beyond.
And what we gives you is a terrifying
feeling of of your mortality.
It gives you a feeling of insecurity,
a feeling of what you can call paranoia.
But cause what it is is you've dropped,
dropped all the blinders all around
you and you realize how ridiculous his
proposition is. Period. There is no way
around the fact that it's ridiculous.
We are in fact just
one part of a universe.
It's above our head. We, there's no,
there's no actual ending to any of it
and just goes and we're a part of it and
we're floating in it and we're only here
for a little bit and we don't know what
we're doing. And everybody knows as much
as you do and you don't know anything.
I mean,
there's some people who know more facts.
They know more about the laws of physics,
they know more about,
but the purpose of it all or
where it ends or what's for what?
Is there a meaning to this? Is this
just a device to move entropy forward?
Is this a device for innovation?
What? What are, what are the humans?
What does this life? No one
knows. Not a fucking one. No one.
That's why you need marijuana. Shit, man.
I want to let you know man. I got to
later. That's what she know, Dude.
That's what we need. Marijuana
commercials. It's not bad for you.
It's just bad for pharmaceutical
companies. Yeah. Cause fuck heads with,
I mean it's supposed to be on America
land of the free home of the brave.
You're locking people up for
a plant that makes you silly.
There's nothing fucking free. You're brave
about that. That's pitch moves, right?
That's, that's, that's a bitch move.
That's the only person who would lock
you up for weed. You know what I mean?
If you had,
if you had to create your own society,
if it was Bert world and you had,
you know,
there's a hundred people and you claim
that you were the king of Burt world and
you've got to establish all the loss.
Could you imagine if you said no pot,
I'll be like, fuck you Bert.
That'll allow pot. Yeah,
a hundred people and make
everyone shaved their heads.
I think we all need to live like they
live in Afghanistan, man. Just warlords,
warlords residing over small pieces of
land. Do you think you'd be a warlord?
I Dunno. I'd worked for
one. Maybe that's better.
You don't want to be the guy in front.
You don't want to be the figure head.
You know you don't want to be Bush.
You'd rather be Dick Cheney.
Yeah.
What I would do is I would,
I would teach the warlord Jujitsu
or something. Warlord. Blacksmith,
you know, I always wanting
to learn how to work shirt.
Make one of those Samurai swords
where they fold the blade over,
over and over again.
I would to take a trade.
That's what I would do.
Really what I'm saying is that I think
we really would be better off if you want
to have any government at all.
It should be very local,
but just a small group and then the only
time the federal comes in is when the
group started arguing and then the
federal comes and goes, Dude's relax.
We're all here to temporarily keep
it together. Hundreds of people, not,
not millions. If in a war.
Lord Brian, what do you,
where do you think you'd fit in in a
world war two he would dominate per crash.
Are we talking about you?
Yeah,
the life of the party part.
I'd be the guy by the fire
lighting the fire first,
putting it out at the end of the night,
like going,
I don't know why I'm all of a sudden
in a fucking village with a fire.
I'm sure we spell it out.
Some story. Yeah. That's why Conan the
barbarian. Barbara was always cool.
I wouldn't make them.
When I was 13 years old is when I became
addicted to Conan the barbarian books,
the Robert E. Howard books.
Really ever read them? No,
I didn't know there were books.
Oh, brilliant. Brilliant books.
We've talked about him a
few times so it couldn't,
wasn't a man a much words
like what would they,
did they just write with
a lot of like narrative?
Oh that's not necessarily true in the
the books he would, he talked really,
but the adventures were sell fucking deep.
It was all about this guy named Robert.
He Howard and what's that guy's
name that's on? Um, he was in, um,
he was in full metal jacket. He played
pile and full metal jacket. Wait,
Vincent Vincent D'onofrio.
Thank you very much.
Vincent D'onofrio played this Guy Robert.
He Howard in a movie about his life
cause Robert Howard was his like really
eccentric, eccentric character who wrote
all these fantastic novels, a fantasy,
but like lived with his mother and his
thirties and shot himself, killed himself.
But he was responsible for Conan the
barbarian and crawl the conqueror and all
these different fantasy books. This dude
wrote. They were fucking awesome dude.
When you're 13 it's a 13 year
old boy's version of twilight is.
It's like they're just these fantastic
fucking stories of, you know,
of sorcerers and fucking sword fights
and demons and it's just awesome shit
man. That's, and you read
that. I never read chapter two.
Those were the books I read. That was
then. This is now they're watching.
That was my shit. Swan Lake or
the route? The little mouse.
That road there might
motorcycle. No, Ralph.
You never got into comic
books or anything? No,
I never had a common goal with my
life. Really. What about you Brian?
You got into college?
I actually just read the walking
dead and I read the hallway.
I started watching it. I just watched
the first episode getting goals,
the comic almost exact like
look at the timelines. A little,
little switched around,
but it's so amazing how well they did it.
So good.
That's the only show I'm watching these
days and the only fiction show I'm
watching walking dead. I tried
to get into everything up. Well,
I still like breaking bad next time I go
to get them when I'm getting my tattoo.
Finished. I'm going to go back and
watch the rest of breaking bad.
You're going to get different braking,
right?
Oh, my shoulder blades. Let everybody
know I'm down a fucking party.
I saw something new, Dude. Some new
white rap dude on TV last night.
Last night. I was up late at
night watching the PAC man
fight. I had it on a DVR.
I hadn't watched it yet.
No
one.
No.
Well
see that's the reason he keeps putting
these bombs out there because every now
and then he just went out of the park.
One memo, Marcus. Anyway,
they had this awesome fighting
and I still hadn't watched it,
so I was up watching it and uh, what was
it? What the hell were we talking about?
What was the point on Pac man?
No, it was before PAC man.
What was the breaking bad tattoo?
You're getting your tattoos.
He only shows you watch. God
dammit. I completely forgot
what I was talking about.
Can someone tweet us real quick and
tell us what we're talking about?
We smoked too much pot folks. It helps
and it hurts. It's there and yet it's not.
What? Ethereal. I apologize. It's
probably my fault. How's it your fault?
Cause you brought a pack. Definitely
threw, threw us off the fuck he did.
But it was worth,
it was worth doing.
You were the one on the fucking Nina,
the Pinta and the Santa Maria.
Go and look at it's a whale and
Columbus was like, whoa. Something
I was watching on TV. That's what I was
talking about. Oh, this new white rapper.
Thanks. Some guy and it's got a song.
I don't know who he is. I don't know.
But he was with that Birdman guy. Manny,
do you know who the Birdman Guy is?
The guy from fresh, I mean
fresh from the hot boys. Yes.
And uh, apparently that is like
the number one guy in the car game.
You know what that means?
Like he always has the freshest cars,
got his cars or read articles
about him and dub magazine.
You should do all the money from juvie.
He gets like $1 million worth of
cars every year plus every year.
Just new cars constantly hooks him up.
Make some like super stereos,
bad ass rims. Customizers
custom colors, like a white,
like a white rapper that
you were talking about.
This guy's in the video with them
so that he's in the video and this,
there's this new guy and he's like, who
in the club doesn't give a fuck? Like,
that's like essentially the song.
And the guy's like got all these crazy
tattoos all over his body and I'm looking
at this bird man guy and he has
this star tattooed on his head.
He's got like something
tattooed on his face.
He's got like teardrops tattooed and he's
got a star tattooed on the top of his
head. And I can watch him. Yeah,
he's the recent images you want because
I'm sure he gets tattooed a lot. Um,
you know, he's, he just crashed. Fuck.
And I'm watching this parental controls.
I'm watching brian.com, by the
way. What am I searching for? Oh,
you're searching for refreshes.
Butthole Birdman, tattoos. Uh,
top of head looked for that. Um, and
I'm, I'm watching this. I'm like, wow,
this is some crazy music.
I'm like,
I wonder what my grandfather would think
if my grandfather who came here from
Italy, you know, in the
1930s I think he came,
maybe it was the 1920s came to America
from Italy. I wonder, you know,
he was like innocent Natera
and shade go over his house.
They would be playing opera music.
I wonder what,
how alien that would be for him to like,
if he could be my age,
if he could be in his 40 sitting in
front of the TV watching absolutely
hysterically. I bet he'd think
it was a joke. I bet he'd go,
I bet he'd look at it and go,
oh, I like really go get a gut laugh and
go, I can't believe this is all areas.
I don't think you would've taken
it that well. Birdman Tattoo.
No, don't put butthole in that
fucker. All right. Hey, Brian.
Brian Olive Garden there. I already
said it. Now you can't say it.
Go Fuck Yourself. How about that?
Huh? Are you kidding me? Yeah.
He's got a bunch sometimes too far east
as west. Isn't that nuts, homeboy? Crazy.
That's wild,
man.
He's got stars tattooed all what the
like look at this guy like writing on his
head, man. Hit Him and get
get some more face tattoos.
W W we've got face tattoos cause I think
he's got something big on his cheek to
man. I was, I was doing,
I was googling Wayne's tattoos because
Wayne's tattoos are crazy to little
Wayne.
Oh yeah.
Those guys are and then I got into the
UFC guy with the swastika tattooed on his
stomach. You know what I'm talking about
and know who got a sweat look at it.
No backup one Brian
God.
But not her. Not Him, but there was
one, there was birdman is above you.
It's above you right there.
See that click that bird birdman
is the lighter skin black ball. Oh,
you've got fucked. This is probably
not what you're looking for,
but here's the virus bitch. I
have, oh wait, you have a Mac.
The virus just don't work.
Amazing.
How many PC people want to
still stick with pcs after that?
Just due to trust me man. The moment,
the numbers of Mac users moment,
they get up to a certain amount
where it's worthy of their time.
Then they'll start writing viruses
we need to do worthy of their time.
Don't understand, but they don't have it
now. Dummy. What kit? What do you care?
You don't can get them now where
there's no viruses. That's better. Whoa.
That's now. There's another side
of his head. The other side.
It's got a bunch of shit
too. I would say. Got,
got someone that's cheek right there.
That one right there. Boom. Fucking shit.
I'd love to be as nurse if he
was in a coma and just read him.
Read them. Yeah. Like just look at his
body while he's out. Like, Oh yeah.
So you don't have to worry about him and
just read everything about his body and
have one of his friends to explain,
oh,
CMH is the neighborhood in New Orleans
who grew up in this cash money hose.
It's a weird way of living, man.
I mean, they, they're making, uh,
like they're making a living,
a sensational one out of just live in big.
I mean that's what they're offering.
They're talking about how big they live
and showing you how they don't give a
fuck getting tattoos and their head
driving around Bentleys. What bitch?
Literally. Yeah, exactly.
Stop me. Stop me from women.
I dare you fucking face.
That's before the stars on the head.
Yeah. That's the one man. He's got
something. He's got something crying.
He's killed three rain belts cheat that
you're not catching in that picture.
I have something written on his cheek.
It's hard to see in that picture,
but in the video you kind of see it,
you know essentially got
writing all over his face.
He's really does have
writing over his face. He's
a wild dude. I'm just wanting to get a
tattoo lately. What do you want to get?
How about that squirrel with
a beer. Huh? I would have,
I would have to get done sleeved.
What was your first one?
You didn't have any on
news radio, right? No,
I had one that I got the graphics logo.
I remember
there's like a demon with a
jester's hat on. I was a retard.
I was like 23 or something like that.
When I got that,
I was such a dummy and I still
have it. Yeah, you still have it.
I, for some reason I thought
you kind of covered up.
Oh, shut up. I drew it
actually. That's right.
I had a guy,
it's actually a pretty
cool tattoo for 1980 89.
I drew that in.
Uh,
fuck.
I drew that in whatever
it was when I had it done.
I guess it was probably
like 1990 or something.
I guess it's not a good idea to
mix electricity. Uh, with the,
the new stadium.
Everything's under control.
We've got it handled. What are you
doing your next hour? I don't know man.
Hopefully soon.
Louis C K style. I like
the way he's doing it, man.
He's just releasing it on the Internet.
That's really the smart way to do it.
We want to figure out if there's a
way to do that. Five bucks, two bucks,
five bucks. You get stream
it live or it doesn't matter.
He doesn't have to be live.
You know,
you should be able to just get it whenever
you want it and then just make it a
podcast. But a paid born on
iTunes, like a rental, you know,
that's sort of a good idea.
But I would have to like,
I would have to set it up correctly.
Can I tell you,
I mean maybe cameras and you know,
make sure it's directed well. You know,
that's kind of a part of a standup is
like when you watch a standup special,
what's really cool is a special,
but what's really underrated is like all
the people that do it behind the scenes.
Like the guy who directs the UFC is a very
good friend of mine, Anthony Giordano,
and he's the one who did my, uh,
my special too. But I'm like,
he's a guy who understands like
how to make something look cool,
how to cut things, how to shoot things.
Like, you know, bring some life to it.
Not just here to record this but
record this and put it into focus in an
artistic way that makes it more exciting.
Yeah.
So I have to have fraud and I were
talking about doing dates together in
February. Oh really? That's awesome.
When I was going to do it, I don't know.
I think uh, Dorfman's brother,
uh, I love half Ron. He's great.
He's a great guy to have on the
road with you too. Great Guy.
He's and he's put together.
What's that?
Well,
nothing microphone me.
Yeah.
Am I talking into it wrong?
So yeah, we were talking
about doing dates in February.
You turn it that way on
purpose. Did I? Yeah.
You were getting really upset
during when we were talking earlier.
Blacked out Bro. He all over the
table. It's all over. Remember? No,
I don't imagine
you had a boat. Get a huge bonus. Do
you guys were tidy? Whities no, I don't.
I've been going back to the tighter ones
lately because I did boxers for like 10
or 15 years, but it was just
too dangerous. You know,
boxers entangled with your dig and
you're like waking up and you're like,
why is my Dick like asleep? And then
you realize your boxers all wrapped up
tidy whities style.
But I wear black underwear because
I don't want to see my farts
splatter paint, all want
to be reminded of it. Look,
this is just a part of being a human
being. We've got to be. That's that whole,
that shit comes out of that.
Occasionally air doesn't leak out of
there and occasionally it stains your
underwear. Are we playing games here?
Why are you giving me white underwear?
Is this a fucking test that I can't
win? Is this a test I cannot. Yes. Yeah.
There's this yellow by my Dick.
This cause my Dick drips pissed.
What am I supposed to do? Get toilet
paper out and dammit. No, I'm a man.
I stick it back in my pants and then we
clean the fucking underwear and then a
couple months I buy new pairs.
That's right. Amen. Amen.
Black ones and I don't
need a fucking hole.
Somebody please provide a solid pair
of underwear thing. Dick Nicole is.
It's just more embarrassing than anything.
Like you're fucking like getting a ups
guy looks of your penis and the only way
you should use that vehicles.
If you have
ugly balls, if you have some
like pomegranate looking balls,
you have some deal breaker
balls. You're like, listen baby,
I got a pretty deck but I got some balls.
It'll scare the fucking paint
off your car. You don't want to,
you don't want to scare off the listen
baby. You can see my balls eventually,
but right now it's just a beautiful day.
It's a glowing sort of passion, lust.
But then you see the balls and
they just like troll eyeball.
The halls are horrible and they drip
the leaking. My balls are so bad.
How bad are there bad? What's
wrong with them? They're,
the ball stops at like say like four
inches five but the scrotum keeps going.
That's because you have a lot of
potential for manliness and it is,
is it's like say if you went to a
surgeon and they were going to give you
artificial breasts,
they would make a nice deep pocket
for a good set of double D's.
You gotta create some space and that's
what it is. You just got a lot of room.
Nice. I, it makes me feel a lot better
about my balls to do that by giant balls.
You can be totally running
shit. That'd be great. If a man,
a doctor told you that he could give
you a them examine. He's like, man,
you're gonna be a great man. This is what
he has to say about a lot of potential.
It should be the greatest
American ever measure.
Potential ball size when it counts in
America has, how big are your balls?
That's really what we admire and if you
really want to get real well we admire
is how big are your balls? What
are you willing to do? Yeah.
How crazy he wanted to get. That's
why I shall look. Jackass works.
That's why you know standup comedy works.
That's why fighting works.
That's why anything crazy, crazy.
Are you willing to, again, I like,
I was watching this show where they were
talking about his guy who died recently,
who is a professional snowboarder.
Apparently he caused an avalanche and
I think I heard about this guy. Yeah.
You know, or I believe it was. I mean
it's happened more than one time.
You know where these like extreme
athletes, they go back home.
Try dropped off in a helicopter. Yeah man.
I like Whoa. Like what the fuck? Yeah,
that's, that's as real as it gets. Oh
d two for a sport. Have you seen you,
I think our only reason I, I take this,
I say I say to you, have you seen,
but the only reason I probably saw it as,
cause it'd be your news feed on Twitter.
Have you seen the guy in the squirrel
outfit jump off the fucking thing and Ms.
Brown miss the ground by like six
fucking Oh my God. It's incredible.
And he's going a hundred miles an hour.
Oh,
that is one of the most amazing
videos I've ever seen. Insane.
What are those called?
Is Wingstop at squirl up as well?
I think they're called squirrel shoots.
That's what it looks like.
It was like a flying school.
Yeah. It's incredible.
It's one of the baddest things I've
ever seen in my life is you'd have to be
absolutely fucking fearless to
do that because one mistake,
one miscalculation of the terrain.
Yeah. Well you don't pull up in time.
And you slam into the fucking mountain.
You're getting a hundred miles an hour.
You are following that is that
is a game changer. A crazy idea.
Who is the mother fucker
that tested that out? Oh,
that it was when I jumped out of a
plane with Rachael Ray. I did the,
I was fucking hardcore
panicked, but I was like, man,
when you're screaming at the
earth at a hundred miles an hour,
there is a fucking surreal moment where
you go, all right, this is it. Oh my God.
If this shoe doesn't open,
it doesn't open and I die with some
dudes strapped on me like a rape harness.
Some horrible fucking in Rachel
Ray Goes Home Pi. That's a guy.
Rachel is like a gangster
and Rachel does I ship? Yeah,
he's got my back permanently
stapled to your back.
He's literally harnessed into
where you can't get, you couldn't,
you can't get rid of the guy.
And it's the most uncomfortable position
to have a man in sitting on a man's
Dick in the,
on the flight up to get to 13,000 feet.
So you can jump out and you're having,
you're trying to have
your own little moment,
but you've got some East German
with his arms around you.
Hold onto you like go and let's,
let's start you up. Tighten up what a,
what a crazy fucking activity you.
But that is 26 people died and there
was like 2006 was a little last year.
We looked at it, an alarming
amount of people die. Skydiving.
An alarming like when you wait, not
that morning. I woke up, I was in the,
I was at the W in, in Union
Square, beautiful hotel.
And I think what could go wrong,
I'm going to just check the odds and
see how many people die skydiving.
And there were like up to this
year. Mind you. I was like, Jay,
it's like fucking August and they're
like 46 and I was like 40 fucking six.
That's a lot of people like that.
I'm not comfortable with those odds.
And that is in a year in a year here and
then you two and then you see a video,
they show you a video and they go the,
it's a, it's an old dude and he goes,
you have to know you're entering
into an activity that you,
that will is likely to cause death. You
May die today and you're like, wait,
why would I want to do this? It's not
that cool. Yeah, it's not that fun.
Like I don't want to fucking die.
But then you do it and you land and you
live and there is a week where you feel
like you have a secret that no one knows
like a fucking week where you are the
most powerful human being in your head.
You see movies where a guy's
running across the top of
the thing in in your head,
you go, I could do that. I jumped out
of a fucking plane. Like you really,
you feel limitless, you feel like you've,
you've climbed the tallest mountain,
new jumped out of a fucking plane
and you live, you, you beat the odds,
you fucking one. And then you
get addicted to that. And like,
like I know Rachel and I have
been doing some crazy shit,
like just doing some bizarre shit lately.
And in February we're going swimming with
sharks and I was like in the cage and
she goes, fuck it out of
the cage. So we're doing,
going swimming with sharks out of the
cage and then we're going to do what's
going on with you and Rachel
Ray's been doing, I mean,
we could do a lot of Jaeger bombs
and then like, you're like, hey,
let's do these ever black out really
nice wine. I have blacked out. Rachel.
Ray's being on you. No, no, no, no,
I'm definitely, we party black car.
You blacked out with her
before we partied in Mexico.
Meet her and her husband and we killed it.
I killed.
I will say I cause I don't want to fucking
thing anyone to think that she drinks
a lot,
but I murdered some wine,
nice wine and her in her room and
her husband listen to comb your hair.
Did he come here to suck?
Cock hold story. Very cool.
Very cool.
Do you want to keep the party going?
You have to tell no tales.
I understand. Listen,
I wouldn't, I would do this exact same
thing. I Love Rachel and I love John.
Who Doesn't love Rachel Maddow,
whatever names current.
Her husband makes me some Lasagna
and we're in a hotel room.
I'm not going to like fuck the guy. She
looks like she's got a great personality.
She's a lot of fun.
She's a human being.
She just seems like like a fun
person to be around. She's a blast.
She doesn't seem negative at all.
Not at one part. Yeah, I haven't.
I don't think I hear it.
She's a rare person too.
That's like a celebrity that you don't
hear people criticizing that much.
I don't really hear people talk shit about
Rachael Ray. No one really liked her.
She's great. She has a loft
down in Soho. You go over,
she has parties really and
videotaped the whole shit.
She for her show and then she'll like
cut the cameras and they show up.
Let's talk shit. I saw Ricky Gervais'
here the night like me, just,
just like really gospel has comedy,
comedy and she loves comedy.
She fucking loves comedy
and I guarantee you,
I guarantee you she's on a treadmill
or an elliptical right now listening to
those shit. If you had another life. I
love these. I love these. If you know,
if young Burt had gone left
instead of right one day,
you know it just spike
some weird stroke of luck.
A 30 year old Bert meets a, who knows
how old she was and you're both Sangal.
Yeah. Let me think, man. It's happening.
You think like if we're not famous, if
you guys had met, no, no, not on payments,
but I'm like saying like just a parallel
universes. I meet her at a Bar, right?
All Dream Girl. She dreams.
She's mothers. Will your wife,
I know my wife's listening. You, your
mother, your mother. Do you want me this?
Rachel's and kind of chick that you
who he's got a son. I've got a son.
You don't know about him yet.
Oh my God.
She's the kind of chick that I will say
that any dude that met her in a bar with
lug it in a heartbeat.
She's so cool.
Does your wife that you talk about her
like this damn, cause there's nothing.
You can't say anything
bad about it or like,
and usually I'm pretty honest
about everyone and, and I,
and I'll find something that I go, yeah,
but you wouldn't like this about it.
But with Rachel it's like everything
you love, you love everything about her.
She's cool. She fucking gets it. Like,
or you can tell a joke, they're like,
we got two bodyguards,
you go to Mexico,
we each got bodyguards and then
as those Gary, oh so great.
And so, and I told her, I said, what
does that, who were the bodyguards?
Mine was Edgar and hers was,
I think his words were worried that the
body guards of like sold information
cause they've seen birth to conquer
and they want you to do a bunch of shit
around their house. I haven't dealt with
cartels. I didn't speak any English. No,
none. But I see it as a joke. I go, oh,
let's take our body guards down
to the beach and make them fight.
And she laughed. She was
like, oh, it'll be fucking
hilarious. Like, like as a joke.
Right, right. But you tell it to some
people in the industry and they'd be like,
come on man, let's not be disrespectful.
They're working very hard.
They tell you the politically right
answer. She just laughed and she's like,
that'd be funny. Like just
a real cool, wait a minute.
You're talking about two trained
killers to train killers.
It's natural to see which
one would kill the other one.
I wanted to track them down at the beach.
She's her correct and her interest.
And so you,
it doesn't mean they should do it.
And then we get to pistol whip the loser.
Whoa.
That's where you want to cross the
line, Mr. Not with me. Really. Aw. Aw.
Come on man. We're in
Mexico. Shit's going down.
What do you do you think it's weird that
there's a third world country that's
connected to us? I
mean, how crazy is that?
The way where we got fucking everything
over in Afghanistan right now.
You know, think about all the soldiers
we have over there. Meanwhile,
right next door is a third world
country with a drug war going on.
It's like having ripped arms
and a perfect uh, chest,
but then just a gut like no in a
rotten ass hole and a small Dick,
a broken small deck, small digs. It
doesn't even work. Like we cut it off.
Like it goes, it goes, it goes money,
money, money, money, money, money.
Like you do not get the mother's money
in Mexico, but you know, the, the big
Mexico City and stuff like that.
I mean,
there's really nice sections
in Mexico City. We were,
we were saying that Miguel de Allende
and it was a very fucking nice,
they showed the Hbo Special, uh, the 24,
seven with Pacquiao and Marquez
and they showed like Mexico City,
like Mexico City is like a real city,
you know, it's a, it's a, a high entity.
It's fucking huge. I think Mexico City is
the biggest city. In fact in the world.
It's really high up.
The altitude is high shit.
I'm guessing it might
have just made that up.
I know that the air quality
there is fucking terrible.
It's really hard to break it
to smog issue. It's real bad.
This is more people in Mexico City I
think than any other city in the world.
I might be out of line though. I think
it's close though. Whatever it is. It's,
it's top. It's right up there. But it's
bigger than any of the American cities.
It's a massive fucking city.
Yeah,
it's got one and I mean you figure our,
the quality of life there has got to be,
it's got a soccer well in some
areas. Yeah. It's, I mean we,
they showed one main wall.
Mark has his place,
like he had fucking a Mercedes and a
Porsche. How do you have that right next?
All that shit. You got to live dangerously
with sun, you know, because you're,
you're flaunting in front of
a large population, half nots.
Oh Lord.
Population of have nots. Who Don't, who?
I'm a man. I'm assuming there have nots
10 times worse than our have.
The difference between, um, uh,
Marquez who's rich in America.
You know,
one Limo Marquez is a world champion
boxer, a famous athlete in his country,
loved by millions of people.
One of the, you know,
tough his boxers on the fucking
planet in this country, in America,
he's rich as fuck in America.
He's made millions of dollars in Mexico.
That must be staggering. Like the
difference between him and you know,
you know, in America him and a
minimum wage worker is substantial,
but it's almost,
you could see it in the distance possible.
Insurmountable in Mexico.
Mexico is insurmountable.
It's insane. It's impossible.
How could someone stay in Mexico
and you know, and you know,
what are the percentages of earning the
amount of money that this guys are like,
this is insane. And so for him to be
flaunting light it in Mexico is like, wow,
that's a, it seemed to me, I don't
know anything about the college
really talking about my last bet, I
bet seemed extravagant, but I bet,
well we're not putting into this
is that he is a Mexican hero.
He's a hero.
No one's fucking with him because he
is the golden boy to them because he
represents them every fucking day.
The, the guy who came from nothing.
You got somewhere.
And I bet that is what keeps him safe.
I bet no one touches him cause they go,
they go,
what are we going to fucking take
away? Or, or, or Adam Rodriguez,
whatever the fuck guys name is baseball
and Menlo Marcus, I don't know,
element like our Derek Jeter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He is, you know, he's
a, he's a bad ass mother fucker. You know,
he and he like fights for the pride
of Mexico to along with it. Yeah.
And he's a Mexican boxer man. Mexican
boxers are fucking gangster. Punched me.
Beat me somebody.
Why you will not stop.
Yeah.
There has been some of the best fighters
ever as Julio Cesar Chavez in his prime
is probably one of my all time favorite
boxers to watch cause he would just beat
dude's down with like volume punching.
He wouldn't punch like
even like full blast.
100% wouldn't you like eight
engage in wild slug fest.
He would just fucking and methodically
move and throw Beaton's on dudes and hit
him with body shots and break guys just
slowly, slowly break guys. You know.
And even guys there were
two more talented than him.
Like did you see the
Meldrick Taylor fight?
Wait, metal teller tellers.
The guy who can barely speak.
Yeah Dude. Yeah. Don't do
what a fight. That was what
our board where it was. Yeah,
I did see that. Taylor was
boxing. Julio, Cesar Chavez,
his face off for most of the 12 round
fight. And then towards the end,
Chavez connects and starts connecting
on them in the final round and nails and
with a right hand and drop some.
He gets up with like three seconds to
go or something crazy like that on the
clock. Richard Steele waves
it off and he calls the fight.
So Chavez came from this
beating but as young,
incredibly fast,
like technically sound Olympic boxer or
he was just getting lit up and it looked
like, wow, you know, he's just too good.
It's too good, you know, he's too fast.
But Chavez just slowly kept
methodically breaking them down,
slowly breaking down to the body
and then eventually overcame them.
And the very last seconds of the
fight overcame him and it would,
would've for sure stopped him if
Richard Steele would make him,
made him stand up again, it didn't
matter. He would have stopped him.
He would have jumped on him again.
Eight seconds is not enough.
He would have last and he was
done or whatever it was. It was,
it was two or one seconds. It was the
right call. Meldrick Taylor was fucked up.
He was pissing blood and
he was never the same again
and he's,
and if you watch videos of him,
he starts with a dip pronounced
that stagger and stuttered.
Well that is one of the most like w like
obvious examples of a fighter who has a
really tough fight,
like an all time epic battle and
then essentially never reaches that.
That performance level again, you don't
know whether or not it's physical,
like it took a lot out of their body,
which you know,
that does play a factor of a real
big beating like that. Like that,
I mean a real war that can really,
those body shots at Chavez hit
him with over and over again.
That can really wreck havoc on you.
And then you also got to consider his
motivation when a guy gets beat up,
sometimes they don't have the zest and
the fire that they had when they were
undefeated and they thought they
were unstoppable. That's me. Yeah,
piss strong dudes, man. They just talking,
you know, young and full of confidence.
They got the world and they feel like
there's, I run into so many guys,
especially in the UFC,
these young guys with this incredible
confidence and incredible confidence,
and then you see them
have a really tough fight.
You'll see them have a really tough fight
and then you'll see a marine gauge and
sort of look at this a little bit
different and go, okay, you know what?
Everybody's vulnerable. Okay,
let's not get crazy here.
Let's not do something stupid.
You're going to do this.
Let's do this intelligently.
And the ones that think that way,
they have a long life in the
sport and the ones that don't,
those are the ones that, you know, they,
they have a few epic contests where
they essentially have a really,
really difficult time recovering from,
whether it's psychologically,
whether it's physically, you know,
those really, really tough ones.
Those are the hard ones
to come back from it.
Getting your oil,
you have one.
Well I think it is, but it's important
for people to, it's a humility thing.
You need to know that that's possible
to you. You can't always be the hammer.
And for a lot of young, fast people,
especially a lot of young athletic people,
they're always the hammer and
it used to be in the hammer.
You're terrified of being
in the nail, you know, once,
once you've taken some shots before and
you understand like this is a give and
receive bitch,
this isn't just to give and sometimes
you're going to get fucked up.
Just like the way you like to fuck up
other people. Sometimes you're going,
as long as we can accept
that and understand that,
then you can look at this whole thing
rationally and instead of thinking,
you know, with this crazy confidence
that you're on top of. So guys,
games change and I could change for the
better or could change for the worst,
all dependent on how committed
they are to their goal.
I follow. It was a bad ass at 15
like bad ass. Why'd you think that?
But I dunno then been beaten up. I was
terrified at 15 really? Very, very, very,
really? Yeah man. And you, I really got
into taekwondo. Yeah, I would didn't,
I just thought I was tough. I
was big, like I was a bigger kid.
Like I was the in the top of the level
of the height and size and I just thought
I was tough.
And then,
and then you get your dick knocked in the
dirt a couple of and you're like, okay,
I got humiliated in what wasn't
really a fight. It wasn't a fight,
but it was a bigger kid who
just did something to me. No,
he wrestled me to the ground. He thought
he like, like hip toss me to the ground.
We were just playing around,
you know, like, um, I don't,
I don't remember what started it off.
I wasn't really that friendly with them,
but I was like, Hey, what's up? You know,
it was one of those things and somehow
or another we were in a of the locker
room, like leaving and we got, we,
we said something and we were joking
around and he pushed me and I pushed it
back.
We grabbed each other and the hip toss
man on the ground and just laid on top of
me for a couple seconds
and I couldn't get up.
I got into how to get up and
they let me up and you know,
he laughed about it and
it wasn't really a fight,
but it was he and humiliated was enough
was you weren't cool with it. I wasn't.
I wasn't cool with the fact that he
could do that. I was like, Shit, fuck.
It threw me on the ground and I couldn't
do it. So then I started wrestling.
I just, I, that's when I took wrestling.
Seriously. Yeah. Yeah. I was like,
that was ridiculous because it was,
I had an inflated sense of what I could
do physically because I thought that
physically I'm a really strong guy.
I know how to strike. Like, you know,
if anyone's going to want to get in a
fight, I'll fucking kicking in the balls.
You have all these stupid ideas in your
head of what you're going to do with why
you're a Badass.
Then some guy just hip tosses you had
lays on top of you and you're like,
I can't give this guy off me. Like I
really, I couldn't get him off of me.
I just couldn't.
I had to give up and he let me up.
It was a huge eye opener, you know?
And then luckily he was a nice guy.
He didn't beat me up or anything
when she had me down. But you know,
it was a good eye opening message.
That's
so funny because I,
I'd practiced none of the real striking.
I would practice the talking before
the fight. You were good at that.
I would do it in my
mirror. Yes. I'd be like,
you want to fuck a piece of this?
I'll fuck you up.
I'll fuck you up three ways from Sunday.
And I'm,
we just practice it and I would like,
like shirt off and like flags every,
every kid did that and every one of our
kids are our guys in like there was a
gang called the caveman. No, no,
no, I wasn't. I wasn't, well, I was,
I was in the gang Corolla,
the caveman,
there's a gang called the caveman in
Tampa and the cave men were like these
public school kids book from the Rich
Public School. And they were like,
they were, they would just get in
fights all the time with Jesuit kids.
I went to Jesuit and I was in a get,
and they're not a gang,
but a club called Apu and Ebu
and cave men fall all the time.
So when from like my junior year, until
my senior year, even my sophomore year,
you always had to be aware of the cavemen.
And so like you'd go to a party in a
fight would break out and would be the
caveman. And so then that's when I,
I was like, I was like, that's it.
I got to learn how to fight.
But I never really learned how to fight.
I just learn how to talk shit.
So,
and then as you're opening move
just to be loud and crazy, man,
let them know that you're
in for some dangerous shit.
I remember the first time ever
punched someone. It was, uh,
the first time I ever punched
someone was a black dude. Uh,
it was the rob that another girl gang,
I think from Robinson.
I think it was called chain again.
No, no, no. I wasn't in a gang.
I was just going to a club. I was in, Hey,
a afterschool club at my school
and everyone else had gangs.
But then our afterschool club was the
one that got involved with gangs because
of the, but it wasn't even
gangs. It wasn't any gangs.
It just fucking high school
kids. It wasn't like real
gangs. So nobody got killed.
No one got killed. Just heat up this
fight. Definitely guys got beat up.
And then there was one like
gang from I think Robinson.
I think they were called TWT together we
foliated with anybody. No, no, no. Yeah.
Well yeah, it was a part of this like
Ebu Group, like the EPA pluribus unum.
It's on the penny that's ours.
Had like some Latin significance to it.
Everyone else TWD together. We thought
so. Cave men. So you were in gang,
not gang is a very strong
word for what we were.
We were a group of guys who are at
school together who likes guys played
football and baseball and wrestled and
we were like the cooler guys at our
school and we were in this group called
Gpu that was a sanction group by this
school. You had initiations where you got
paddled and you initiated into it and,
but it just happens that the one guy,
the head of EPO in like 1988
got into a fight with a caveman.
And so all the fucking Apu
or is for cavemen, Ebu,
fought whoever when
Robinson or Hillsborough.
And so at a young age you realized you
had to stay away from those fucking
people. So the first punch I ever thought,
so it was, I heard a fight is a story.
I've told him stand up many a time,
but the, the short, the short,
honest version of it is, and was
at a party, someone you'll fight.
And I thought all of Ebu, all my
friends were going to come and watch it.
And I roll out. And it's,
it's one caveman, right?
And the whole TWT together.
We thought posse,
like it's all black dudes
and one white caveman.
And I stick my head in and I actually
know this cave man. I know, I know who,
I know his reputation,
but he's unconscious on the fucking
floor because there was Mario,
he was fighting this guy,
Donovan and I stuck my head in and second
I stuck my head in. They were like, oh,
here's his brother, get him to, and
they pushed me in and I was like, well,
I'm not as brother. I know he was friend.
Like we're not, I'm not on anyone's team.
I'm on a different team like,
but they think we're on the same team
because we're wearing the away uniforms,
you know,
so this guy be the beat the
shit out of me standing.
Does that make sense? Like I
didn't fall, he didn't kick me,
but I never at any point did,
it looked like I won and I did a lot
of trying to talk my way out of it.
But while he was hitting you, you were
trying to talk to him. I was like, man,
I'm not, and you just pounded me.
And he was like, he was like, oh.
And he was talking shit. Like as he was
fighting me, like I just weird shit.
Like you follow me, you me round them
all mother fucker. And I was like, what?
And he's like, follow me around them all
bitch. See what happens. See what happens.
This is what's up, this is what's up
and just pop in me. And I was like,
I got the chicken. So the first
punch I ever threw was then, uh,
and I go to throw a punch,
but I never thought a punch before.
I'd only worked on talking shit.
So my shit talking without door.
So I'm getting my ass kicked.
So I go to the hole punch by just,
it was more like a hey, like it
was like a, like a, yeah, like a,
like a stop. Like, Oh,
you break my heart. They
get, oh, and I literally,
my hand landed in this high top fade.
It went into his hair. Okay. And, and
I remember thinking to myself in this,
this is,
the joke is very different than this,
but the truth is when into his hair.
And I held it there.
So I thought I'd never talked to a
black person's hair before and I,
Collagen moved my fingers around
a little bit. He didn't move.
And then all of a sudden the
cop showed up. Oh my God.
When the cop showed up and then all the
fucking brothers fucking took off except
for this guy, the cop showed up because
they knew there was a fight going on.
Cops showed up. Tuesday, odd cars,
conscious two squad cars, two rednecks.
And the other guy is still out cold. I'll
fucking cold. Would they do to him? Uh,
he was just laying on the ground.
He's the lanes you got there he is.
He'd already been knocked down.
He was that guy when I stuck my head in,
he was unconscious. And this Guy Donovan,
who is standing over him, beating him,
pummeling him though. And I fucking
stuck my head in, thank God I did.
The kid might be dead, but I stuck
my head in and I was like, oh,
I don't want any of that. What? He
ordered it. I'll take something else.
That kind of damage when a guy's out
and a guy gets beat up while he's out
kicked his head. Like sometimes
people never recover. Yeah.
That dude that got really fucked up
and a in La Dodgers. Dodgers. Same.
Yeah, cause he was wearing, I guess he
was wearing another Jersey from another.
I should have scares them. Who knows.
I mean maybe he did other things.
I don't know why they beat his ass,
but they definitely shouldn't
have done what they did.
What they did was horrific man.
It was a nightmare.
I have no idea how that guy behaved,
but you know they need,
obviously they need more security.
There's no way they should be allowing
that many people that do a place like
that to a position where that kind of
shit can happen. Oh the dodger stadium.
Sketchy. Tighten that down man. You know
when a guy gets beat down like that,
like shit man, you, you need to be
able to protect people from thugs.
There should be out fucking guy.
Code numbers are too high.
What this first of all
those people or who?
Anybody who would do that as a sick fuck
and you know what we're having here man,
it's, it's a classic example of people
not caring about terrible neighborhoods.
Those terrible neighborhoods have more
kids come out of him and more kids come
out of them. They want to do fucked up
things and that just the way it goes,
it's not part of the country. You know
what, that's a very accurate statement.
Cause I,
the other day I realized I don't judge
a man based on his skin color in the
slightest.
I judge them based on their age.
Age is the most fucking determining
factor when we were in Amsterdam. Dude,
a lot of smart young dudes,
man.
I mean there's a lot more today I
think than I've ever met in the past.
I meet dudes that are like 20 years old
that are on the fucking ball and that
does happen, but it's a lot. You know
who's throwing punches at bars and bars?
20 year olds.
It's always going to be that man.
He's always gonna be a
certain percentage of them,
but I think not a lot of 39 year
olds stolen fucking sucker punches.
He's there are planning some losers.
It never got it together. Yeah man.
You underestimate.
There's a lot of good of Vegas.
Go ahead and hang out in those fucking
crap dens and watch the degenerate
gamblers head of the horse track.
You know there's,
there's plenty of 30 and nine year old
man. She can't share anything. Yeah, yeah.
They're just tired or less white and I'm
happy you don't have the gumption ended
quicker.
Yeah.
They just got the gumption to get up
and give me a fucking ass kicking.
It really depends on what
they ate for lunch. Yeah.
They might've had a
burrito and they just got
no energy and they're just ready to shit
their pants. The Guy Talk Shit to you.
When was the last time
a guy talk shit to you?
Oh, I don't know. I mean, it happens, you
know, it hasn't happened in a lot of time.
Most people were really nice
to me. I'm very lucky, you
know, when people say like,
what's the downside to, you know, people
knowing who you are when you go to the,
like a stranger or
somebody paid to do that.
A stranger,
what the fuck are you eating Dick?
Who paid to do that?
Thank God you're broadcasting meeting DMT.
So yeah. You haven't had, you
haven't had a confrontation?
No. People are generally cool. Did you
ever think I'm nice? You know, I think,
you know,
if you come to me with some sort of a,
a predetermined idea of who I am or you
know what you think about something I
said once and you know,
you're angry at me, dad,
it's probably not gonna be a fun
conversation to have that had that happen
before where people misinterpret
something I said or taken out a contact or
disagree with it, you know, and that,
that can happen. But for the most part,
most of the people that meet me or Nice,
Nice. And even when someone does like,
listen man, it's just
an opinion. You know,
they'll have to get people get so God
damn attached to their opinions, you know,
if you know,
if you just just stop and go,
who the fuck knows and stop and go,
well maybe you're right.
That clears up a lot of shit. You know,
it's really simple and you know, and,
and they had a little Google add
that to the mix and you know,
you should be dealing
with much less problems.
We should have because of Google for real.
And we should probably have,
I'd say a 75% reduction in
arguments between human beings.
They should be resolved 75% quicker
just from the access to information.
Because how many goddamn arguments when
we were kids came out of one guy talking
about his fucking ass and you know in it,
but you not having an encyclopedia handy.
Oh yeah.
And you just would fight that.
You don't fight that until
the day he knows you.
That's a cock sucker that thinks
that movie went straight to video.
It didn't go straight to video.
They don't even make movies straight
to video that it was fucking,
it was all in the movie theater
theaters for at least two weeks.
I know because my dad told me those
are frustrating conversations man,
and you never had closure can,
it's more as knows that Kenny's worries
was even say fucking the movies go to
straight to fucking video. And
I was like, that doesn't happen.
It was a fucking nightmare fight when
we were kids when I still remember it.
Yeah, we had fights. We had, I would,
you'd argue with someone and you just
get into it with them and you just would
never have closure and
you'd fucking be like, fine,
we agree to disagree and I'll just hit
your guts secretly behind your back.
Bert Kreischer talking about how
he and handles relationships.
Everybody has their own approach to,
what's yours? Call us now at one 800.
What is it? Chicago right now. And I have
a question for brick right here. Shoot.
Um,
my wife has three nipples,
but both of them are on her ass home.
She has three
circling her asshole.
Like crop circles.
Yeah, they're in there inside. But if he
can feel them with your finger, right.
And if you come down here, we'll
what we'll show you. It's um,
I need to know what to do that
he needed to bail on this. Wait,
no, no. Wait. [inaudible] failed.
Impromptu actual breast area where the
nipple would have been where the Areola
is.
There's an aerial would no nipple.
You ever dated a girl who essentially
an aerial and no nipple of your dating
girls like that?
I've had,
I've dated girls that's aerial is have
been chopped off and then they've had
boobs put in when it's so dry.
And then it's like,
that's like a ghost nipple in some
ways. You know, that's not like a,
you know what I mean?
It goes,
what is that? Is that a real
song? I just made that up. Listen.
Yeah, that was, that was a song that I,
we were barbecued one night and we
were hanging out with him and he was,
he had just started dating this particular
last and for some reason we started
singing a song called,
I saw your girlfriend's buttle
photographs of her.
And here's a picture of her right now.
Is that, that's a nice picture.
It's from Howard Stern pitcher,
but Brian, how'd that happen? How'd you
ever hook up with a chick like that?
You Sir? Do you have sex magic? Do you
have sex? Totally Naked Brian? Yeah.
Well when he's like the pool,
I certainly like the pool.
I usually wear a jersey like a polo.
Like have you ever had,
if you ever had sex with clothes on,
I guess you have like
quickie sex with a shirt on.
Kevin James I would think would have sex
with his shirt on because I didn't know.
But he seems like a guy that he's
always got a hat on and he's always got
something covering, you know,
Kevin is an interesting guy.
Kevin's a really interesting guy.
I went to his house one time a long time
ago and got fucking Ballato in front of
him and I just watched him
look at me like studying me.
Like how does this happen? Like how it
would be like blotto drunk toy. Yeah,
it was me and Gary [inaudible].
Gary knows how to put them away
and Gary started drinking in Vegas.
I've been an ended at,
at Kevin's house many evening
drinking with Gary back in the day.
God Damn he is a,
he'll put them back and he's a good dude.
I saw him all the time, guys. I saw
Gary Valentine one time at the Improv.
Take a shot of a candle.
He took a ship time,
shut up and put it back into the stuff
that was on a funny shot. All right,
let's keep going guys. Keep
going. No, he drank it for you.
Just fucking shot it back. Get a
candle shop. Let's keep going guys.
Man. Gary Valentine's a
fucking party. Got, did I ever
tell you what happened? Oh,
this is my favorite. Sweet. I maybe
I did. Wait. So did I ever tell you,
what did you do you remember Mike? You
know Mike Burton, Mike Burton, comedian,
bald, Jewish, good, good body. And he's
a man. I don't know what I'm saying.
That
caring,
not like it just works out.
He's working hard. Comma,
guy he preaches is really
system of martial arts. He
teaches Krav Maga right now.
So anyway, so one time me, Gary,
and this Guy Scott Henry and,
and Mike Burton are all drinking it for
most of cafe. This is like Thursday.
We don't have to work. Gary
and I are making money. We're
doing an show. And I go,
I go guys, let's go to Vegas. And
everyone's fucking, and except for Burton,
he's like, I don't want to go.
Burton was a comic and he was,
he's stopped doing comedy since he was
funny, but he wasn't like that funny.
So he goes, I don't want to go. And Gary's
like, come on, come on, burden, let's go.
And he's like, I don't want to go. I don't
want to go. So we got to go. Fuck it.
I'm going to my house,
I'm packing my bags.
I'll meet you guys at Scott and Burton's
house in like in like 30 minutes.
So we go meet me,
Burton and Scott go to Scott and Burton's
house and burn goes off. Fuck it.
I'll go, I'll go burn. And there's what
you do hide in the back of my truck.
We're taking my Escalade,
a navigator or whatever and the
way back hiding the way back.
And we won't tell Gary you're
going until halfway there.
Well when when we get halfway to Vegas,
you pop him and go, surprise, I'm coming.
So he goes, that's a great
idea. That's a great idea.
So we fucking pack the
car and we're waiting.
Gary Valentine pulls up and his parks
his car and he comes up and he's like,
what's up? I said, hop in and we're
ready. And he was all right, Scott.
Henry's driving my truck, Gary Hobson,
the backseat, and he goes, where's Burton?
And we'd go, well he couldn't
come. And Gary Goes, let me
tell you something about,
about motherfucker. Let me tell you
why he's not a good comic for one.
And all of a sudden I'm looking
in the rear view mirror.
I see Burton's heads sit up
in the way back and he goes,
because he's not fucking funny and I
don't have the heart to tell him he
shouldn't like,
and he starts fucking tearing.
Burton apart ended and we are in Hollywood
until we get on the fucking 10 all of
a sudden Burton go, I go, Gary, can you
reach in the back of Basmeh and beer?
He reaches back and he sees
Burton. He goes, hey, burden.
Hey turns, it looks to me,
cause you're going to tell him he's in
the fucking car. Oh, most uncomfortable.
The whole rest of the ride to Vegas,
they just spoke like in the backseat,
just talked,
hashed it out and no one spoke to
each other the rest of the weekend.
Fucking uncomfortable.
There's sometimes dues will blow up
and they don't even mean exactly what
they're saying.
They're just frustrated with their own
lives and they find something about
someone else, whether it's a minor
glitch in their system or whatever,
and they just start poking at it.
And it's sort of a distraction
to turn that same, you know,
objectivity and insight to yourself.
You know,
I, I, yeah, I've, I've done it.
I've done it like when I was less,
but when I was younger in this business,
like I would definitely take apart someone
I did not know and look at their act
and be like that fuck.
And I would,
you could get me started on someone and
I would destroy that motherfucker and
pick apart everything. And then
all they had to say was, hey man,
I'm a big fan of your stuff. I'd be
like, I'm a big fan of you too. Love you.
I've been a big fear for a long time,
but there are dudes that are annoying.
I mean, there's no getting past that.
There are guys who get up
there and they're annoying,
but you just can't avoid them. You know?
I just avoid their acts, you know? That's,
that's the best way.
Just to just, you know,
kind of get out of their way when
they're up and just, but you can be that,
you can do it when you're young a lot of
the times you got to follow that person.
Well the follow was not the real issue.
It's when someone tells
you what you can't,
do you ever have that
when you opened for those?
Oh fuck that. Yeah, that is, that is a
some real negative dudes out
there. Oh, that will start to like,
like micromanage your act when you work
at like be clubs. That happens a lot.
Oh yeah. The headline. I will tell
you, you could, whatever you do,
you can't talk about,
you know,
you can have like your whole opening
bit about farming. Like yeah.
How about I have a different bit about
farming and you do, is that okay? Yeah.
You know like what the fuck dude,
you can't tell me what I can't talk about.
It's one thing.
It's like a guy purposely tried to step
on your material in that I'm sure you've
had happened where they you
open or you have like one day,
well you'll be the headliner and he'll
be the middle act and he'll have a
certain set and it'll do well and then
you'll have a bunch of bits on certain
subjects and all of a sudden the next
night he magically has these new bits that
you can tell her new bits.
The cut off short,
they that expanded on and there are about
the same exact subjects that you taught
and they're just,
sometimes it's not even just stepping
on what you're about to talk about.
He's trying to make your act
less effective on purpose.
Fucking exhausting and it's
happened to me so much.
It happens to a lot of comics when
they're like third in there in like 32
they're not making a ton of money in
the making 1200 bucks on the road and
they've got some feature. I could make
it 700 bucks. I was like, fuck this guy.
I've never heard of him.
I'm going to take,
I'm going to make sure that they flip
flop this at the end of the week and they
sell like five DVDs with two tee
shirts and they'll undercut your sales.
I'm selling the DVD for 20 bucks and
this guys, I'm selling all my shit,
but 25 Bam. It's really
unfortunate. You know,
the only way you should go
to do shows when someone is,
if you're friends with someone,
like I don't like dealing like eve.
I love doing the k rock shows because
I know all those people that do those.
Like they have that big April fool's April
foolishness show on April fool's Day,
April fool's day, weekend, whatever
it is. And it's always that, uh,
that huge place and a universal,
what does that theater and universe,
it's like 6,000 fucking people and
it's all a lot of people that I don't
normally hang out with,
but everybody is really funny.
You kind of know him
off from the business,
but it's way more fun when you're working
and you work on the road with friends.
It's way more fun. Like it's,
there's not like for whatever reason,
some comics want them to be the only
one that is getting the laughs. Yeah.
It can't just have a good set
and then you have a good set too.
It's a company, it's a
competition. It's one on one.
Like I'm the funniest
motherfucker in this club tonight.
I need to be the one that when they exit
they go, you were funnier than that guy.
They need that
and then it becomes what we
were talking about earlier,
before we even started rolling
about being addicted to killing,
being addicted to killing is the worst
thing that can ever happen to a comic.
Because I heard you and brewer talk
about this maybe seven years ago,
six years ago, and it was
when it was, when Dane was
blown up and you guys were saying that
Dane is the perfect guy that's addicted
to killing, that he, you know,
it's like what we exactly what we
were talking about with your friend.
They don't want to stop doing
the bit because the bit works.
And even though they know it's
unethical to continue to do the bit,
because it's really your
story that they're repeating,
they can't help it because
it's so powerful. It's such a,
it's such a weapon to use. I'll give
you want these people to love you.
You want these people thinking
of the funniest guy ever. Boom.
How about this brilliant impression with
this perfect story that is so fucking
hilarious. You're going to be
holding your stomach laughing.
The brilliance of it all.
But in reality he shouldn't be
saying it and yeah, and yeah,
and there's an addicted to killing it is.
It's hard man,
because bombing sucks and they,
and a lot of times people think that
bombing is the alternative when it's not,
know if the alternative is
just not killing. You know.
And I think a lot of those,
a lot of guys who, uh,
especially like, uh,
like I remember a tell never killed
Amelie. Like he always killed to comics.
Like we always loved them. But like a
lot of times he'd do 50, 50 in the room.
And at the cellar because,
because in all honesty,
he was working on new shit all the time.
He was always taking a bit and it was not
about the crowd. It was not about them.
He knew if he wanted to,
he could murder that crowd in a heartbeat.
For him it was about the
art and find the right way,
how to kill someone with a hammer.
Like what's the funniest way to kill
someone with a hammer? How do you kill it?
Like, and he would, I swear to God,
he must've said kill someone with a hammer
150 times as when I lived in New York
and tried to work that out and you'd
watch him and I'm Louis C K was about,
it was about him figuring shit out.
I worked with Louis right after Georgia,
my old, my oldest was born and,
and Dave, right back to back.
And Louie and I'm, I'm, I'm
saying this in all fondness.
Louie bombed for an a weekend. He had
a rough weekend. Uh, and he, but he,
but he was doing all the material
that defined him as a comic today.
That is the murderous,
shameful hour.
What did he did the shameless
or shameful shameless.
The one that defined the definitive
hour of Louis CK where you went, okay,
he's my new favorite comic. He was
doing all that and he was working on it.
For him it wasn't about killing.
It was about getting this
concept of being a regular guy,
thinking your kids or a Dick,
wanting to be wanting to eat
whatever the fuck you want.
Being married to someone
who's a little micromanaging,
like being kind like B being Louis Ck.
He wanted to get that idea
out so he didn't give a shit.
I remember going up murdering as a feature
and then Louie would go up and kind
of like
struggle and figure out who's figuring
shit out and you could definitely see who
was working and I remember my head going,
I was so fucking impressed
that he did not care. I'm,
I'm sure he cared about killing.
I'm sure that mattered,
but I was so impressed that he didn't,
he had a bigger goal, you know,
he wanted to create new material
quickly. Yeah. He wanted to make,
he wanted to make, he wanted to
change his style. His style was goofy,
absurd, you know, kind of.
I always, I don't know why,
but I think of like top, uh,
top 10 fucking humor.
For some reason it was like,
it was just like goofy's hop tend humor
when, I don't know why I say that.
I don't know what I mean. But I
always thought of that. I don't know.
I don't know how else to say
it. Oh, do you mean like, um,
like one of those like a poll,
like top 10 funniest things to happen?
Like that kind of humor? No,
no, no. It was like, it was
top tent. Like a tent. Yeah.
Like it was like a tent.
Like,
I dunno why I think that maybe it's our
special had a tense old stuff was it was
still a silly goofy. Yeah. Like,
yeah, he'd go, uh, his joke was like,
I want to see me order anything. A old
diarrhea or down diner style diner style.
You wanna see a diner
style order, ma'am. She got
two eggs, Bacon and pancakes. He goes,
want something to drink? She's like,
orange juice. He goes, all right,
I need to monkeys. Right fired car.
I need to flapjacks them up later on.
[inaudible] [inaudible] need to do
this whole fucking hilarious rant.
Then he go and I need two eggs over
easy bacon and pancakes with some orange
juice. Like that was the bit, wasn't who
he is now at all. It was more absurdist,
but man, I remember watching
that and going, motherfucker,
I wish I had the balls because
I was a feature at the time.
I felt like if I didn't kill,
I wouldn't work ever again.
Yeah.
That's like the fear,
the fear of the hardest part of coming
up with new material or changing gears.
You know,
God forbid when you get a guy who's like
a musical guy and decides to try to put
the guitar down. Oh Shit Man, I've seen
that go horribly wrong. That's east shore.
He used to yell at them.
She used to yell at,
and there's a series of guys that were
guitar comics who I'd like some kind of
funny songs,
but they resented the fact that they were
not considered legitimate comedians by
the rest of the comedians. Like they did
something that was like a little extra.
If you just had to go up there and talk,
you really would. You would eat dicks.
That's a little like not, I
mean, look, here's the thing.
You pull out a guitar and everyone's like,
Ooh,
it's good. Yeah. Nothing wrong
with it. Not saying anything,
but what,
what I'm saying is there was a bunch
of guys who've got pretty good with a
guitar and then they tried to put the
guitar down and just go on their own
personality and they would
eat the sticks up their butt.
Mitzi shore used to yell at them.
I'll never forget the student
was on stage and he was,
he was just choking it up there. I
just didn't have it and it just, it was
out of rhythm. He didn't
know how to another rhythm.
Yeah. He didn't know how to,
we couldn't just introduce the next song.
Next Song I wrote when I was thinking
about I dream of Jeannie and bubble bath
with my dog. Hey man, you know
there's no, there's no setup.
It's just you doing stand up and you know,
you continue to know there's
no guitar to pull out.
There's no pretending you're having a good
time. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
You know, soliciting claps. There's
none of that. It's just you talking.
There's no like a tuning the guitar when
you need a, Oh, let me hold on one sec.
And so Mitzi, the kids on stage
doing this man, as he goes,
go get that.
Get Joe Amber going
stage without the guitar.
I kinda wish I had known missy.
She's one of a costume meter.
Really? Sure. If you want us to meet
her. She's, she's in poor health though.
She's had a hard time the one time
he was a dick. Well, you know,
I'm a big fan of his brother. His
brother Scott. He's a good buddy of mine.
I love that guy.
But I said to Paul in front of Louis,
Louis Anderson introduced us,
always mixed. Louie Anderson Hall,
you should be calling, can be a nice guy.
He's got the potential to be a nice guy.
He just doesn't know
his shoes to be totally.
And it seems like whatever it is there,
it's really weird because every time you
meet him and like most of the time it's
like, hey, he's just a nice guy. Very
Fun Times. And then he has like a bad,
weird side,
I guess.
Yeah, I dunno. You know, whatever.
Did you ever choke him out?
Me? No. Nope. Never did.
I never got. Never even
really, I mean I got it more
upset with how ridiculous the whole
situation, the comedy store. Then
Pauline, Pauline was just a part of
a machine over there. Yeah. You know,
whatever position he plays in it now,
I don't know.
Speaking of that machine,
cyber,
so Monday I got machine
shirts@burpharbert.com keep
going. Fiber sale Monday,
cyber sale, Mondale Monday. So what,
what happens? What do they get off?
They get like a same price as normal,
I think. I don't know how to change it.
They get same prices on a cyber sale.
That's not a fucking cyber sale right now.
Cyber sale at [inaudible] Dot Com oh
and it put in the code word cyber.
You get 25% off and you don't,
you don't have a real,
I actually think that everyone should
go to Doug dicom instead of going to
amazon.com that's d
you go to d g g e d.com.
Brian explained to me why that's good
because I go to the, if you're going to
shop on amazon.com uh, Doug got calm,
just forwards you to amazon.com but any
of anytime you spend a dollar I get 6
cents and it goes towards this studio
that we're not charging them anymore. Huh?
It doesn't charge them
any more for the product.
I know that gives you a kickback.
Just gives it a kickback for promoting
people to amazon.com stealing money for
themselves.
Yeah.
Are we making money on this
side of the apocalypse?
Because how Amazon's gonna fold.
Yeah. I get your shit together.
You're my favorite at all.
The online shopping.
I went to black Friday, by the
way, and that was straight up.
Scary like that was like,
that was like being at, uh,
like Woodstock. But if it was like all
rappers, I guess, what did you get?
What did you get a black Friday?
Uh,
these projectors that in the background
and stuff like that. But it was a,
these projectors right here?
Yeah. What does this movie?
Uh, I don't remember. You have a
plane, but you don't know this studio.
This studio is starting to
become really fucking bad ass.
So wait. So now you guys, do you guys,
do you do a live show here?
Wednesday nights?
Uh, we do a live show here on
various evenings. We don't,
it's not like every Wednesday night
anyway, here is to do the podcast.
What we do is we do a
podcast while we're doing,
I just kicked over his camera as, he's
still cool. What we do is we do a podcast,
like while everyone is going up on stage,
the other comics would be back
here having a podcast. Oh, come on,
please do this anytime you want.
What is the next 100% open invocate maybe
this week, maybe let's figure it out.
We'll figure it out. I'll do it
this week. Do it this week? Yeah,
if we do it this week it'll
either be Wednesday or Thursday.
Most likely Wednesday.
That's what happened is they are talking
about doing is doing something like
that on the road with Ustream and
like fucking trying to, but I don't,
I'm not good with that.
She could do it dude.
Just to advertisers to just
Twitter make a little Ustream show.
It's half runs in charge of everything.
You let them be in charge.
He's good at that. She's smart as
shit. He put together online survey.
I'll have phones.
Brian,
he's a great guy too and he's a fun
guy to have a new road. Yeah. Yeah.
He's a real dude. You know.
She real good guy. He'll heal.
You'll have a good time like me.
Him and Charlie Murphy went on
a one month toward the country.
It was a good time there. They're cool.
Mother fucker. Tony Murphy, he's so
interesting. He's a great guy,
man. I really loved Charlie.
I rented a trolley in Hawaii once.
Man,
it was one of the fucking coolest
things ever. Just random on vacation,
the exact moment he was on vacation.
He's one of those guys,
like I was truly happy to see him. You
know, he's a, he's a real legit dude.
He's like,
so he's the one of the most honest
people I've ever met that's in like show
business, you know, like he,
he came on the show and was telling me
a story about his wife passing away. Oh,
I heard about, you know, raising
his kids and doing the best he can.
But he's still us to travel on the road
and sometimes you have to leave them and
he doesn't want to and how it
breaks his heart, you know,
it's powerful fucking shit. I love
when he, I love the words he chooses.
He's got this, he's got like a,
like a, a 90 year old man's vocab
look. He says words like, tickling,
you are Kruna Yo Karuna like a crooner.
Who the fuck his feelings on the
matter. So it goes, it goes here.
That shit that Mike Tyson,
is that like barbershops stuff
or like Jay guides diamonds?
How do they not have a
black barbershop podcast?
If we got you together with Charlie
in a room, you and Charlie Murphy.
All I want to tell her a
story off. Oh, I want to,
I want to do is start the story off with
Charlie Murphy. Me To go out one night.
Right. Having evening and then us both
recant our evening to you. Oh yeah.
But I think like that anymore
challenge got kids. Let me with this.
There's young white boy with his
smile and laugh that fucking laugh.
I'm fucking
black guys not play gay shit. Brian.
That's a good way to get knocked out.
Silly brothers. White guys. Love it. Look,
if I can sneak around and put my dick
on your shoulder, you'll be like God me.
And listen,
there's a lot of black guys and they're
just looking for an opportunity to punch
a guy like Yo.
So I hope everyone is joking
back off of that shit.
I want to do the Po, I want to do that
podcast that you do here. Absolutely.
Please do it. So are you in town? This
whole went down bird like two weeks.
Oh my goodness. Ladies and gentlemen, you
are listening to this organically occur.
We are making an appointment for Bert
Kreischer to be a part of the ice house
chronical.
I'm going to get a fucking car service
out here are the favorite new club here
in California. Man, we're,
we're doing shows here all
the time as often as we can,
and we're doing podcasts here all the time
as often as we can. Fucking great man.
It's awesome to be as Joey Matt Flavor
going to be here if he's here. You know,
you never know, but you can't
call doily dog. Listen, listen,
I've got things to do dog.
I'll see you at the fucking show.
Like he doesn't like the crown Swartz
and before the show and we'll do it in a
heartbeat. He'll do it. He'll do it
for sure. That guy so much. Yeah,
it cracks me up, man. He's so fucking, he
only did the podcast for like 45 minutes.
We're going to have him back on,
right? There's like a sports game on.
He's like a big sports
guy. Yeah, he's a UFC fan.
Huge UFC fan them all the time
with the UFC and he loves it.
He's one of the sweetest
guys in this business.
One of the coolest things about doing
this podcast and one of the coolest things
about, you know, just being a comic in La,
it's like you get to meet a lot of God.
Damn interesting people
tell me now I think about
our lives in that respect.
You know the, all the,
the wild stories that you told me you're
fucking drinking store with Johnny
Knoxville and like just the nutty
shit that you've told me in the past.
I think about how fortunate you are
in comparison to the average person.
The average person doesn't
have those kind of experiences.
The average person does it live.
So we're insanely fun a, I get it.
I get it when I go on the road because
the documentary guys will attest to this
and I say this and I
say this and I mean it.
I get the fans of this podcast come
out to my shows in fucking droves,
like droves.
But here's the most interesting thing is
they know I'm a fan of the podcast also,
so they end up sitting and talking
to me for the entire night.
We sit at a bar and end up talking
about our favorite podcasts.
So we ended up bullshitting
about this podcast and then,
and then inevitably they're like,
what's Joe's house look like?
And I just make up some story about
talions and fucking what's Italian? Oh,
fucking some thing I just made Allen.
Yeah,
I was fucking talking about Brian.
Did you really work for NASA? Okay,
well that's cool man. Yeah, look, we love
doing this fucking podcast. It's a great,
it's a, we were saying, I was saying
on the phone with you last night,
we had an in depth conversation and
I'm saying this podcast has made it,
it's so fascinating to be a part
of because when I stand on stage,
the second I got on stage, I see droves
of people in machine shirts all sold.
I got two pairs that you got to exhale.
I got the sort of the light one,
which I prefer a very thin
sort of, um, of fabric. Yeah,
I've got one that's like a regular cotton
t shirt. I prefer the super thin one.
It's got a little bit of sexy to it,
a little extra sexy.
You're the reason those things sell.
I swear this documentary,
you're the reason Henderson Sjogren's
shirt on. I'm not the reason dude. All,
I am a, as an antenna that tuned
into the greatness that is Bert.
That's what it is. We just found
you. You know, like I couldn't,
I couldn't make you funny. I can't
make you interesting, you know,
having you on this podcast,
it's just, we're lucky.
I've never subscribed to the idea that
you know, that someone should be happy.
You know that they come
on someone's show and,
and are entertaining as fuck for
free for hours. We did. We, we,
we, you know, we have the,
some really hilarious fucking
shows with you, dude. Oh,
thank you. I thought it was
good. I didn't make you,
you made yourself to your you well it
but we were talking about last night and
it is a neat thing to be a
part of because when people,
when you stand on state
people who love you,
so this is the fucking craziest thing.
So I go to,
we do this special and Amsterdam for
showtime. I get on stage and Amsterdam,
all Dutch crowd, although it's crowd. Wow.
Can I stage and I stand on stage machine
fucking 13 people yelling the machine.
Am I fucking lying right now?
Where's the crew out in fucking Amsterdam.
Dude's are have the machine shirt on and
they're screaming in the machine. Wow.
In Amsterdam now this is,
everyone's had a rub you that thing
about the podcasts free every week. Yeah.
Fucking whelming but it's free and it's
everywhere and it will always be free.
Yeah. My ads are annoying, but
it's always going to be free.
Fucking gray pug when you do
with a tail is overwhelming.
It's one of my favorite interviews I've
heard with the tell because especially
when you told him he could smoke cause
you in all of a sudden Dave start really
parking relaxed.
Yeah I knew I couldn't,
I just turned on the machine and I was
like well no big deal. He's, I love him.
I you let them smoke and he for him,
he a two pack a day guy.
So for him it's super hard to elbow.
Everybody harassed Doug's Dan hope.
Please get after him. Email him, get him
on Twitter. Tell him to do the podcast.
Wise's he's in town this week cause he's
doing the Irvine Improv as close to Dan
who's in town this week I'm
calling up a fatwa to uh,
attack the email of Douglas. Stan hope
Twitter, Twitter and Twitter. Oh yeah.
What else? Doesn't read his
Twitter. Read his email either.
I'm going to call him later.
It's his Facebook is Facebook.
Facebook does this cause he a little girl,
14 year old girls book like page
trying to whack ass shit. Is that,
what does that Shit Brian explain it.
Did you get another fucking coach
got caught with little kids. Yeah,
another coach today. Some,
some fucking, uh, I'll, I'll
look it up online because a,
I took it.
Is this the one is this one
Colin Quinn tweeted about,
did he, did he tweet about it? Colin
Quinn's Twitter is so fucking funny.
Talk on Twitter has been trolling
everybody with this thing about a will
Ferrell.
Saintly.
He stole the idea bill Farrell and do it.
A lot of bad drugs.
He says bad drugs like you can't see.
That's a Colin Quinn joke right there.
He was saying, Hey Josh doing a lot
of bad drugs and they picked up,
they picked it up on the newswire.
Right. It's so silly. It's social.
You can't see him saying even the
vernacular he uses the words he chooses.
He had a, he was doing a lot of
bad drugs. That's a God damn joke.
He's Collin Quinn. The fuck is wrong
with you. Bebo Oh, Bobby Kelly,
give me the result. I want my
mind, man. How do you not know?
Brilliant. Bobby Kelly told me
the funniest Collin Quinn story.
I saw Bobby in New York, we
did his podcast, which is
coming up next Monday. It's,
well, you know what the name
of his podcasts, it's really,
it was really fun as podcasts called
know what news? You know what dad,
that's a great name for a podcast.
So, uh, so, so Bobby says,
have you ever met colonics? I'd
never met him, but I love him.
I think he's hilarious. And then he,
I see Bobby later that night. He Goes,
you know, Collin said Hi. And I said, I
don't think, I don't think we've ever met.
And he goes,
well,
he was at Gotham the other night and he
sat with a guy for 30 minutes and then
at the end said, see you later Burt.
And the bike guy goes, I'm not Bert.
And he was all right,
take care of.
He thought he was talking
to me for 30 minutes,
like having a conversation with some
guy and the guy. That's hilarious.
You Burton, the guy who was, my
name's is Burton. He was like,
oh wow. So you guys just sat down
and talk politics. Maybe ghost man,
that goes, Bert, this is what I was
talking about. This guy from Syracuse,
that's who it is.
Syracuse University fired Bernie fine,
assistant men's basketball
coach for sexually abusing boys.
So that,
that shit happens all the time now.
I mean he molested half
of our elementary school.
We talked about this on the podcast.
His name was filled me up Philips and
he would just like walk behind guys and
smack them in the butt and he had like
this huge bucket of like prizes that were
like stupid small toys.
And it was like a joke between us
in elementary school like, oh yeah,
he molested our friend Sean. He molested
her frame, Blah Blah. Yeah, true.
He really did molest them. Well he
didn't just making shit up. No, no.
I mean that's what we all believe.
But we're on the elementary kids,
but then later. But did these kids
tell you that he molested them?
I don't know how it was one
of the things that got the,
throughout the whole entire school people,
and he has been a rumor,
maybe even at an even as well. Even
as a kid, we all were like, dude,
he totally is so molested and oh wow.
And that's crazy.
Few years later he got thrown out of
school or whatever for a or a or whatever.
I don't know. But he got suspended for
doing that. But you dodged it. Oh yeah.
I wasn't,
his kid was too fat.
That's a defense mechanism.
Joe [inaudible].
Oh,
make your cell phone.
Unpretty you don't feel purely on the
inside to make yourself unpretty on the
outside. That's how I get out
of most of my relationships.
And if it goes after five or six years,
I just start eating like crazy.
He's not lying. He's not lying.
There's one point in time,
he was at the end of this relationship
and he had to weigh almost 300 pounds to
six to 63 60 pounds. Yeah.
And then told you that.
I've done that before where I'm like,
I'm just gonna eat a lot and get rid of,
get rid of them.
That's the most self destruction way to
get out of relationship I've ever heard.
It's hard,
man.
How hard is it to break up with somebody
that can pass a big test though that if
they can last for me being fat then
then all right, they deserve it.
But it is or what your Dick and deserve.
Well me being sad story, thicker,
thin bitch. So you do it on
purpose is what you're saying.
Here's the thing that there are guys in
unhealthy relationships right now doing
destructive shit to try to
push the girl away and, and,
and here's the thing that I
learned one day in a yoga class.
I was in a miserable relationship
right before I met my wife.
I go to a yoga class and the guy just
does that fucking gets in your head.
You do the whole class
at the very end he goes,
so right now when we lay down on the mat,
I want you to think what's the
one thing that makes you unhappy?
I remember thinking this fucking chick,
and he's like,
you have the power to change that
today. Take action. And I went,
I can fucking dump her like I was.
I can make myself happy right fucking now.
So if you're listening and
you are thinking to yourself,
I'm not happy with my chick,
fucking change that shit.
Absolutely change what a good mood
to do is also is to sit down and give
yourself advice. Nobody ever does that
self evaluation
actually give yourself advice.
Say if I was in this situation,
what would I say to myself? Because
nobody ever does that. There's no,
what am I going to do? How am I
going to fucking, you would say,
what if I was saying this to somebody
else? Let me take myself out of it.
It's very difficult to do obviously,
and you can't be 100% objective.
You should get to know you have a
situation would sit, sit back and say,
how would I advise myself to handle this
situation and then fucking foul that
man, because that's the person
that's thinking clearly. Not You.
Now he's looking for a
shovel and some lime.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You've
totally fucking right.
It's the guy going, that's
funny. It's true. You know I
never fucking listen to me.
You got to go into the isolation tank.
I want to go into the isolation.
Take really bad.
I want to get in the TM two.
We should get one here on
meditation in the isolation tank.
Fucking that's what I want. Get
one here. We could do one here,
but the only thing is I'm really has to
maintain it. You have to make sure we're,
what space would we do it? But it at
Brian, uh, the isolation tank, uh,
that room next door is there where you
can rent it out like a sore. But whoa,
we could do that.
Start off float lab
lab is in Venice. If I talked to crash,
we'll say we'll talk to the flow.
I want to do your license. How would it
be? That would be dope. Dope malicious.
You know what? I got
an idea. I got an idea.
I think I might have
to open up a business.
We're going to open up a tank
business. Brian Ryko right
next door. Genius. Genius.
I can't hear out of my left
here. Uh, one of these,
because it's not a good headphone.
We should get new headphones.
Scott Stole Candy. They sent me to them.
I keep forgetting to bring them here.
They're at my house though,
diligently waiting.
Did you bring a five HTP with you?
Yeah. No, I don't have any with me.
I have this big thing at Alpha brain,
slow roller myself.
My personal goals, and by the
way, if you take new mood,
this is the five HTP thing and you're
taking antidepressants already,
it could be a problem and yeah.
Yeah. Apparently that's a Dr Site.
So they say if you are,
cause apparently what I'm Neal Brennan
was doing when he came on the podcast and
he started taking them out talking about
antidepressants and five HTP and hey,
you know how it helped him.
His doctor told him essentially that
what's happening is when you take five HTP
and you're already on antidepressants,
it's like getting to antidepressants but
you'd actually get too much serotonin,
which is really crazy because what
that means is that five HTP essentially
produces much of the same stuff that
these antidepressants produce. It's like,
it's almost like it's natural
antidepressants saying,
what about new mood and Stella, I
think that works. New Mood and Stella.
Oh is it?
The beer will stele is a good beer.
If you want to let a chick
know that your European, yeah,
let a bitch know
Ben the London three or four times.
It's cool.
You just got to go the right restaurant.
I got friends in London.
I got to let them know I got
the Lens in London. Yeah,
I guess she was made out of kangaroo
drink that I'll have a Stella. Stella,
I think in the glass is nice. I like it,
but it's like a light beer. I S in a glass
without skunk light be without Scott.
You know what man? Give me one of
them bitches. I'll try it. Its role,
its rolling stone burden.
Fuck this one beer.
What are we
to be a man of our stature?
It's how much you weigh. Two 32
25 I'm like one 90 we can. We can.
Yes. Nice Brian. Thanks Brian.
You're a fucking gentlemen.
Now I got to go back and
have a conversation with
my wife and my daughters.
It's not gonna be half as an entertaining.
Oh it's going to be fine.
My daughter's last night.
That's what pop comes in and makes
it even more interesting. Again,
I'm trying to help you
try to help you burn.
We're going to turn you into a pothead.
It's going to help you. Let's do it.
Here's my friend. Cheers to
uh, to uh, to a great stem.
The studio to great new students.
How do you say the last name?
Ah, like, like already full quad Artois.
It's okay.
It's got like sediment as a
bottle ban or would good. Um,
you know, what's your favorite
bit for Sam Adams? Heineken.
I'm a Heineken guy and if I didn't get
a high, if I get sponsored behind again,
I'd do it in a heartbeat. I remember
one time some Budweiser guys asked me,
they were like,
how much time,
how much would it cost to
get that Budweiser out of
your hand and put a Heineken
or on stage or get that Heineken in your
hand, put a Budweiser and on stage. Wow.
And I was like, can't do it. So you
would only drink Budweiser on stage.
Just drink Budweiser on stage. I
did. I did it deal with Jamison.
I didn't deal with Jameson. Jameson
for two years. Much crazy shit though.
I don't think Budweiser.
No, no, they don't.
You seen the commercials look
at their super bowl commercials.
It's pretty much what you think of when
you're taking a shit. Maybe. What, what,
what Superbowl commercials are you
talking about that you think of what you'd
taken a light or Budweiser commercial
commercial. Pretty ridiculous
versus sponsor to the UFC.
So I have nothing but love for Bud light.
There was that Brock Lesnar was, they
got nothing on. Yeah, well he was just,
he kinda like made a joke. He was trying
to be, he's trying to be as character,
you know, like he's, he's, you know,
the heel from pro wrestling's big fucking
wrestler guy. He's selling himself.
He's doing a smart thing, you
know, so he just fucked up.
He shouldn't have said that,
but he just fucked up.
But Bud light was like the first big
sponsor to step in and support the UFC.
So I'll always be a bud light fan
just for that. It sounds ridiculous,
but that's a big move,
man,
for a company to take a big
chance like that and step in.
Do you out on sports
for Awhile? Yeah, dude,
I remember hearing this
shit and being like, God,
did you guys go through that honey brown
stage where everyone was drinking honey
brown and killing it?
Brian, you always do this.
You always change the subject.
When we start talking about
MMA immediately while we
were talking about beer to
us,
we were,
but people on line and going to get
angry with you every time you do it.
So when, when I worked for Jamison, I
worked for James from for two years.
Did the Jamison tour me, Billy
Gardell, Steve Byrne, my goal, Loftus,
Nick Griffin and Danny Bevins and you,
they sent cases at Jamison to your house
every fucking month they sent cases of
pace is of Jamison nug Spence chicks.
But kids drink it all
and know when you got to,
we show Jamison waiting in the green room.
Oh,
and the rule was you had
to drink Jamison onstage.
You had to mention how
good your Jamison was,
but put it on the show. Like take a set
like Dan has good fucking Jameson like,
and you had to like, hey everyone
today, like you had to be pro Jamison.
I got no problem with that.
Cause Jameson is pretty God damn good.
It's fucking awesome. Good
Shit. We get done the tour.
Are you ready for this?
They buy us each of them acre of land
in fucking in Ireland on a river.
All of us right next to each other.
We'd get a fucking Acre land,
a deed and a picture. Whoa. Yeah.
Fucking Jamison was one band.
You got to build a house in Ireland now
you can't build, you can't build on it.
Build on it.
It's fucking pointless.
Can you camp on it? You can camp
on it. Yeah, they can be to him.
Billy Garden be permanent. Can
you have a present tent? Yeah,
but me and a bunch of psyches be
fucking t w O. Pikeys. Yeah, dude,
I've been obsessing about watching
these Irish travellers fights to me.
Some of the uncles, oh my God, they
have some of the best fights, dude,
you got to Brian, you've got to look
this up. They're boring as shit.
I mean most of these guys,
but they're tough guys and everything.
But there's a different style of
fighting when you fight bare knuckle and
literally they stand there for
lunch themselves in the face.
It's not like a street fight like you've
seen in the states have used that one's
they challenge each other
and they challenge. He said,
I'll tell you that Johnny.
Johnny Mac. Yeah. Good for nothing. That's
how you get a good fun happen and yet,
cause I've got bosses Heidi off at all.
I have to tell you right. Don't know.
Fight. I'll fight cha anytime before
Christmas. Any time a hawker center,
there's a beauty, there's a video of, of
a pikey driving to a street. They said,
well meet what do be a quarter of
the clique to rise it up here is it?
And then whoever knows that one between
me cause I, I tweeted it a while ago.
It's really hilarious.
But I can't find it in my Twitter
while the show is going on. But I,
I want to play it because it's so,
it's so ridiculous.
He something really
disturbing Irish travelers.
Then there they were talking
shit before a street fight.
It's even better than the actual fight.
Most disturbing pikey video on
there is most disturbing one.
Every week someone's listening that
knows exactly what I'm talking about it
please tweet it to Joe and me and Brian,
it is pikey gets what he deserves
and it's a bunch of a British school.
Kids in a park having beers, snorting
coke, smoking weed and a pike.
You will comes up and he won it,
but it's all done post. It's a,
it's a recount of the British kid going,
so a little pikey comes up and he wants
to little drink. He wants a thing.
I didn't do this and that.
Well we tell them it's cocaine,
but guess who just got a nose full of k,
a special k and they cut in the pike.
He is fucking seizuring on the
ground. It's bulky, sketchy.
It breaks your heart because you go,
that guy's helpless.
He's in a k hole right now. He's not
coming out anytime soon and it's all,
it's if you, if you type in Brian of
you typing pikey gets what he deserves,
park or something like that, you'll
see it and it fucking, you just go, oh,
that shit happens. That fucking
happens. It does happen. But man,
he was pikey fights were greived fucking
was obsessed with those for a while.
Here's one of them. Brian, can you
find this? I'll tell you the name.
Tell me when you're ready.
All right.
Big Joe's Davey Joyce.
Reply to Simon. Oh. Oh,
shut the fuck on. I'll
wait. Is this a Vlog?
No. [inaudible] so one
more time. Okay. Big Joe's.
Just type in big Joe's Davey Joyce reply.
Just type in that big Joe's J oes.
David d a v Y Joyce.
J. O. Y. C E reply.
Hello Simon.
Wait,
hold on.
Stop.
Brian. You got two things
playing at the same time.
There's two things playing his him and
then there's something about going on in
the background.
Did you hear it?
It was the thing that Burt told me
that, oh, I'm sorry. I was baffled.
I couldn't hear how horrible. Just
want to hear this guy's blog. Yeah,
he's what it,
this is what's going on here.
There's a guy who was talking
shit about him online any time,
but time Jen.
Now this guy came back to reply to
them anytime between now and Christmas.
Here he goes,
how about now? You ready by? We can all
do that. We don't fight with the hands.
The hands come up over time.
We cannot do that fight. Yeah,
don't be squeaky clean.
Always take their shirts off.
We get seriously even when
they have terrible chess.
Do you want me to slow it down a little?
No. It was beautiful to keep up.
Hope Your Fred or with the
stamp of it nigger like Peyton.
They need the rat poison. Hold demand
dinner. You're squeaky innocent. No,
no, no, no.
You look like you're the
shirts off body like that.
Prep on your body like that.
That guy's getting aroused.
Dependent and England. I
would fucking fight. Fight.
Fuck. I know. This
is my first time to you. What
he did keep your brain damage because
of swingers club will lift your head.
Have ever had that
thought he could put that in bath.
You dirty good for that.
But the company, should I
talk to chuck? He's password.
Your worst nightmare. I'm your worst
nightmare. I was like, Anthony,
we caught you. Shake the
pocket for a whole two weeks.
Give me all, but it was finished. We flew
from Dublin. No delay at the trailer.
You were trying to live off for 12
weeks. What? Simon? I am crystal.
You now officially shy
him. The Poconos. Well,
I'm calling you to wise.
I know we're going to be shutting the
fuck up at 12 weeks as well so that you
wear as well. It's shaking the bottle.
What do we call you? Shy in the box.
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, stop. Stop this
real quick. Can we, can we please do this?
Okay. Listen please. Anyone.
Everyone right now. Uh, do their
response video to this guy. Go.
I don't know. No Shiny, but I know
you and I will fucking kick your ass.
Who the fuck do you think you aren't like,
do your American take your shirt off.
Let's see how good they can get.
Oh fuck. I want to do one tonight.
Who's second we get done, Brian, get a
camera. I'm doing a reply to that guy.
What's his name? Big John. And I'm going
to be dead. Fucking serious. So big John.
And either, you know,
he doesn't get irony.
He's going to be sitting in
this chair like one Una fuck on.
Is the slow mode him that he's got to use
these. How many ways can you use these?
John was going to use
these shirts coming off
the shirt coming off as a strange move.
Cause especially it guess it's it.
I don't give a fuck move.
It's like that white rapper that
I was talking about earlier.
Who is it takes his shirt off. It's like,
oh do Kumu. Fuck the guy with Birdman.
I don't know.
But he didn't give a fuck.
His whole thing was that
he didn't give a fuck.
Well this guy basically is doing the
same thing. He doesn't give a fuck.
It takes his shirt off. He
knows he's fat. I love it.
He knows he's not
pressing shirt comes off.
That's when the fucking postop Phil Baroni
under there. You know, that's not a,
that's not a young Randy coture.
Come on son.
What are you looking at now, Brian?
You're looking at funerals, bagpipes,
and buttholes. It's like
bottles. Put the bag.
It's grown, man. Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm fucking, what's that guy's name?
Big Junctions only
answers big John McCarthy.
That guy's name was
Brian is that guy's name?
I'm fucking Pau d'arco. Davey
Joyce. Reply to sign. Big,
big Joe. Debbie Joyce. Alright.
To Stymie to Simon. Oh,
Donald Shaman. He was saying Simon this
whole time. That's what we were saying.
All right.
We're going to need some cue cards,
so I'm never gonna remember that guy's
fucking, I'll, I'll, I'll send it to you.
I'm trying to see if I can send it
to you right here from my phone.
There's gotta be a way.
Me
Too. Yes. God. That's what's
great about the Internet.
I would ask you what your email is,
but then the whole world would know it
and you think about changing a bunch of
black dicks in the mail. I just had
to fucking pay for new, more g space.
Really?
Yeah.
And that's just disgusting to me that
it's gusting from penis pictures or
sending out, no, it's, I think it's
from just sitting a lot of movie files,
video files and stuff like that and I
wish I could like just be like, hey,
let me download it all immediate like
in one file and then erase everything.
Right, because it's only
five, five bucks a year.
But still it's like if you stop paying
it and then it takes away that space,
that extra 20 gigs they would pay
for every year. It's kind of a trick.
And then if that keeps on going,
that's going to be like a gas price thing
and like in 70 years we're going to be
paying like $5,000 a
month for g mouse space.
I think you get out of hand
with the oldest that Google
has everything for free.
They'll control the monetary system
of the world and it is. She made them,
they will be our overlords. Do you really
truly believe that Brian did? You know,
I think it is a trick that that they
make you pay for a 20 gigs Esther a year.
And if you don't pay, yeah, but if
they don't, if you stop paying for it,
then they just, what the elite the last
year of your Gmail, it's kind of like,
why should they give you so much storage?
That seems like the type of stores
that have propelled. Why? You know,
why they know why they should.
Because I got just make a second gene,
Gmail for free and a third
g mail and a fourth g mail.
Telling them right now he's given
me what does that against the law,
giving away the secrets, man.
You know what I'm saying now?
What do you think about the
latest and Google phones?
Because I've been having these Google
phone versus iPhone conversations again
lately.
We stopped with this.
It's like the downed that's supposed to
know exactly what you go by your fucking
phone and you'll know and like an hour
and month you'll be back to the iPhone.
I know 100% you would 100% what
if I like looking at big pictures?
I want a big pictures.
Big carry your iPad around on a
sling like he used to battery. Fuck.
Oh Fuck Joe. That's the next
money maker right there. Uh,
I want you to come out with man like
Ma fanny packs mainly fanny pack.
I got one right here. We have a
um, uh, higher primate fanny pack.
Nevermind.
Most ridiculous.
One of all time back is more like a
survival camp. It's good for cameras.
It's tough.
You carry too much of a guy on the field
that needs like a belt bag. It's like,
it's too ridiculous for a fanny pack.
It's a guy at work. I don't know.
It's pretty tough. I like it a lot.
It's still sexy with it on though. Yeah.
I don't feel bad cause I think it
looks so ridiculous when you're around.
Your girl just looks like Gi Joe Style.
Like it's not like when you look at
fanny pack you're like, all right,
that's just lame. This to me it's
like more like, oh, he's his guy.
A good camera and some stuff in there.
You know what it looks like to me
it looks like the big bad wolf.
I'm going to put it on right
now with the big data set.
I started watching that show grim
on Sundays. Grim. We, when we,
are you ever going to talk about your
new show coming out? What? Fairfax? Yeah.
Yeah. I'll talk about it. I'm
fucking, are you, are you excited?
It's going to be fun.
It's a funny show.
Everyone I talked to
[inaudible] excited for it.
I don't know if there's one episode
where I'm not sure if they're going to be
able to aerate. They haven't decided
yet. Are you serious? It's so crazy.
It's so ridiculous. Like when I heard
that we were doing it, look, I'm,
let me tell you something. The way
they're filming it, the, the, the stunts,
everything is like way more
over the top than before.
Let's stuffy a way bigger and it's a,
it's very strange looking at Brian.
Brian's gotta succeed. That's your
fanny pack Brian. Yeah, look at that.
That's like a survivor gear
sort of a thing that is a whole,
that is a fucking shooter in the field.
Fanny pack. You could do some serious,
but traveling with that though, you know,
that's a good move for the airport dude.
So you can film us going through the
airport. A lot of foam that though, right?
I don't know. We're trying, we're going
to fill him in the airport. The Tsa,
they allow you to film
the,
he was saying they use another camera.
The other camera is the 70
and it's a little more, uh,
it looks like a film like it will
you just walk around with a, your,
you're knocking. It looks like
you're carrying a fucking camera.
This is one of the most shocking things
about traveling in Europe is you realize
how much more lax they are on security.
They're much more relaxed.
It's much easier to travel there.
Oh,
I flew in very nice and friendly
and easy going. It's not,
it's not nearly as investigative as
when you land in America. Oh God.
You know,
I fucking,
when I flew from London to La and coming
down in London was a cakewalk and,
but man coming in to, here's the
worst part is what was the problem?
They asked you a lot. But the biggest,
the biggest problem really was I don't,
I wore so many different outfits in
Amsterdam evening wise and I had so many
fucking chaotic nights that I
didn't know what was in what pocket.
And I literally packed and I was like,
I'm pretty sure I'm clean,
but who knows who fun. And did they
know you coming from Amsterdam? Uh,
uh, no. I took a train, I took
a drink and I'm like flying.
I took a train from London,
Amsterdam and then took a train
back from Amsterdam and London.
It doesn't show on your, um, no.
They asked where I was and I told
him Amsterdam and they said, why?
I said vacationing and here's the kicker.
I had like a $30 Cuban cigar and I was
like, fuck it. I'll just roll with it.
I'll take it home and smoke it at home.
It's a Cuban cigar butt.
Take the wrapper off.
They'll never fucking know.
And I told my dad and my dad goes,
don't fucking do it to $250,000. Fine.
If they catch you with it, well they
could move it. They cannot prove it.
If you just stick to your
guns and say it's Dominican,
I'm going to fold like a cheap sheet.
I'll be like the, I'll be like,
the opposite of Kaiser says
is your, so they take me away. I didn't
mean to. Oh Man. I don't even know.
That's a good cigar man. Why don't
you want to give it up to the man?
I have to give it up. I don't fucking
ruined even if 10 grand, if they said,
all right, well let your weight with 10
grand fucking puts a dent in my family.
Yeah,
it is kinda crazy how all the rest of
the world is allowed to buy cigars from
Cuba but not us. And Man, it tasted
so good. Assholes. We're still mad at,
you know, they're letting us buy land.
Cuba. Would you buy land in Cuba? Uh, why?
Why did I do that?
I don't know.
Overwhelming need to go
to Cuba and plant things.
If you're an n of murderers anywhere
that I wouldn't want to live,
what would you do you imagine?
What are you milling the way?
Hemingway in the fifties ready to make
your own hotel out there and have the mob
come down and run everything again.
Good old days is
a lot of people in Cuba.
I bet long for the good old days
and the mob was running shit. Oh,
that must've been nuts, man. Mom
Brung Cuban, the 1950s you know,
when you think about like what those
motherfuckers were in to back then,
you know like,
like Kennedy,
how Kennedy like almost flaunted his,
you know,
friendships with all these high level
celebrity entertainment figures.
And you know how all these hot
chicks are on them all the time.
Talk about rule list like lawless,
go to Cuba,
right in the what? Fifties sixties Oh
my God. Okay. Let's try to think. Well,
what point would they prosecute you?
Like you could kill someone totally
in Cuba then. Yeah. Oh, of course.
And what to you guy has got to,
I don't know,
Cuba's history enough to
know who's the most corrupt.
It was the most corrupt before, before,
before Castro. Even when Castro came in.
Technically. But Eddie Bravo is a
huge Castro fan and so is Joey Diaz.
You sit down with Joey D's helped break
it down for you forever about Castro,
the good and the bad. Really? Yeah. It
says, you know Joey was born in Cuba.
He was born in Cuba. Yeah. He was
born in Cuba and came to Miami,
came to America when he was really young.
Shut up. Yeah. Joey Diaz is a real deal.
That's why he doesn't really know
how old he is really chilled.
Yeah. Joey Diaz in Bert Kreischer
have a lot in common. You know,
we both deal to be a really,
really funny person.
There's like a certain level
of unconventionality a certain,
a certain frequency of vitals. Give
a fuck that has to be reached. Yeah.
Not everybody can reach that,
you know?
So when the guy comes along like you
and reaches it like that, you're like,
oh wow. He just took a fucking
pill from Johnny Knoxville.
12 shots he just did. He's a number
one party animal for rolling what?
You know what I mean? Like,
yeah, they just, you know,
there needs to be an event that
throws you the conventionality.
After that rolling stone article,
there was nothing I could do.
I wasn't going to get a straight job.
Who the fuck's gonna hire a guy that
took his shit on a pizza box and won an
election? Important man. It's important.
It's important for
people to push the issue.
I'd never had a,
I never had a happier day in my life.
Brian and I were driving him to your house
or from your house one night, one day.
And Brian and Joey called Brian and
Brian and they started talking on the
speaker phone.
Comfortable cause you brought it up while
I was in the car and I just felt like
I'm dropping. So I just said,
I go, Hey, uh, we're talking.
You go, hey Joe. If he goes,
hey wait guy at Joey Diaz,
I'm just want you to know I'm in the car,
I'm in the car. I just want you to
know I don't like, God forbid they go.
And you know who's on the podcast
today by mark. I see him, I see it.
But it was I'm, but I've
listened to so much of the
podcast. I go, I'm just saying,
I'm just saying, Joey, I'm in the car. I
just want you to know that. And Joey Diaz,
just real smooth goes,
I might shit.
I was like the machine.
Well good. The great
you know, you, you and
common speaker phone. It's weird
though. Like that right though.
Do you get calls a lot Joe,
when you're like,
you have to announce it to the Colorado.
Oh yeah. I don't want it to
anybody so fucked up. Fuck.
I always told my wife not to say
the n word for it. Unfortunately.
You already said that on a
previous video blog. Did I fuck?
Let's get that fight video wrap up for
Joe for a big Joe Davy. All right. No,
let's shoot mine. Oh, oh, in your video.
I'm ready to fucking challenge him.
Your stance that he's a dead, you know
good Boston. No, I'm going to go to ocs.
Them fighting.
Is this,
this is the video you told me to search
for it earlier or no, this isn't a thing.
This isn't it. All right. Well that seems
like a cool fight. Videos. Yeah, it does.
If you just type in Pikey, you'll find
so much great shit. Snatch snatch. Is it?
Yay.
Is it gay?
If you put a picture of shirtless Brad
Pitt in fight club in your man cave,
so it inspires you to work out. Absolutely
not. That's what I'm talking about.
That movie is awesome.
Not that I'm doing that,
but I have a friend who's thinking about
doing, I think it's awesome. What do you,
you love him as the ideal build? Is
that what it is you'd like to look like?
Look like that? Why can't you do it?
Uh, I'm trying. I'm trying to. Ours,
we've got like a maniac. I'm trying,
I'm working on book like crazy.
I'm not eating this grass fed meat.
Thanksgiving kind of threw a wrench in my
work around like a fucking savage lift.
A lot of weights to trick your body into
thinking that it has to do this all the
time. Had a bench press and the fucking
hotel the other day in New York fucking
pounded out high school strong like
one 35 I'll do they shit 10 times,
10 times, 10 times. Now
what are you going to do?
You're going to just touch the bench.
Commit to like a serious weightlifting
program and weightlifting and running.
I'm running hardest shift for an hour
and I'm lifting weights, push ups, plank.
I just want my body to be, I got to get
my blood pressure low, lower, and I want,
I just want to be healthy. I don't want
to be a fat old man. I want to live.
I want to look. I don't want to look
skinny. I don't want to look perfect,
but I want to look like I want to
take my shirt off at the beach and go,
I bet he has an active lifestyle. You
know what I mean? Instead of saying like,
I saw the way your belt, like when you
showed your tattoo, your belt doesn't,
it holds your pants up.
It doesn't define your waistline like,
does that make sense?
I see what you're saying.
Like my belt cuts into my fat.
You have me to under my pubis and
my stomach. Sometimes it bleeds.
You have to put a little neosporin on
it. There's no bandaid. It cuts into you.
It's corn syrup.
The government government cards here,
it's cholesterol, trans
fats. That's what it is,
man. It's the government
keep me a fat and stupid.
No and no time in history of
people who've been fatter.
I don't think there's ever been a time
of history where the numbers of people
who've been fat like in this country,
the numbers are gigantic by Fatman use
get respect in the 20s when you were
buster Keaton and you were fat.
They're like, how did you do that?
That's why you were a movie star.
Like, yeah, Babe Ruth. Oh, I'm here.
Everybody was like, he must have
a lot of money. Yup, Babe Ruth,
who's eating steaks and
hot dogs and drinking beer.
He's living high on the hog and
then now you're just fat. You just,
it looks like you're poor and don't care.
Let it looks like you just unhealthy
and then you just have a poor diet.
Had No connection with
your personality anymore.
Such a direct connection between what
you put into your body and how your body
feels mad and some people just,
I have friends,
I got a buddy who's on antidepressants
and he eats terrible. He's fucking die.
It's awful.
I think it's lack of women.
I think like the old days used to have
a wife and they used to cook for you,
like he's nice meals and stuff. To
me, half the time I'm like, okay,
a Jack in the box is open. A subway
is still open. You know, it's,
it's more of like I'm more rushing around.
I, if I were to come home like, oh,
you know like family dinners style, you
have to kitchen table and you're in your,
she's like, oh, I made a
casserole. You like, wow, that's,
you've been watching too many patty
Duke movies. That's how I grew up.
That's how you go. You grew
up. That's how I grew up.
I had family dinner every day. I hadn't,
you know, we all sat at one table,
still have family dinners bro, and they
were super unhealthy. I mean a family.
Then it doesn't necessarily make it
healthy. What, what the real problem is,
is most people have terrible dot.
A woman in the is,
what I'm saying at the house certainly
helps men. That definitely helps.
If you live with someone, if
you have kids, even, you know,
you all like have good food in the house,
you know,
you want to make sure everything's supply.
When I lived alone,
I ate out every fucking night of
the week. Oh. If I lived alone,
I'd be in great shape.
Yeah. When I lived alone,
I was just a comedian and
a TV show in the morning.
Some way in restaurants, restaurants,
everywhere. For breakfast, lunch, dinner.
I would keep some food at home just
to eat when I was starving or if I was
writing or something like that. For the
most part, I just went somewhere to eat,
you know? Why would I cook? I
don't have time for that shit.
What's the one thing you miss
about being single the most?
No, no, no ma'am.
I don't miss new pussy at all
because there was always a,
I had to do a song and dance to explain
why that didn't go the way they thought
it would. Like I would
never, oh that's so sad.
That first new pussy experience you had
where you would go in and you'd get on
top and you were like, all right,
this is going to happen really fast.
And you knew that in
your head you're like,
the whole thing I'm trying to do is make
this not prolonged this moment so that
she thinks it's somewhat enjoyable.
The only good parts about being single
are that you can have sex with more than
one person.
The only bad parts of being single are
that you're lonely and you're single and
it's way better to have a relationship.
It's way better.
But the problem is we're fucking a wired
to want to have sex with other women.
So it's becomes life becomes a matter
of managing your desires and managing
which ones manifest themselves into the
real world because they can cause a lot
of negative energy and they can cause
a lot of arguments and they can cause a
lot of lonely nights.
Like you gotta like look at like what is
the most logical plan of attack to have
a happy life. And what is the most
logical attempt to have a wild,
chaotic roller coaster bride of
those chaotic nights were then,
well, you're standing on top of a corner
of a building in New York and the sun's
coming up and you've got to fucking girl
from Liverpool next to you who's tongue
stuck to the bottom of her mouth.
And she's like,
oh well I need a more normal pack of
cigarettes. What turns his door open?
That fucking shit.
When you
find yourself fucking in a parking lot
in the middle of downtown Manhattan,
you find yourself just doing
crazy shit. Yeah. But you know,
ultimately it's fun. But the real
problem with single being single,
the real problem is meeting cool
people. It is fucking hard, man.
It is hard to find the real person.
You got to go out with them for awhile
and you got to talk about controversial
subjects. You have to,
you know, you have to,
to get to know him and know how their
brain is for a lot of fucking fools when
you're saying, my goodness, you
put a nickel for every night talk.
And I watched
this guy on a date once, and I'll
never forget this, I was, I was,
they were to a table next to us and the
guy was talking with this girl and the
girl's talking about her dog and
how her dog is so used to the finest
automobiles and Mercedes
Benz and you know,
and she was like going off about her dog,
that if she ever tried to
bring her dog in a taxi cab,
she doesn't think her dog would go
in. And then she was like, it was,
it was just chaos. God. And
I was just imagining like,
could you imagine if you get just
stuck sitting down to this next to this
fucking dummy and you're actually having
this conversation and she's not being a
joke. She's not being
ironic, not being hilarious.
Like that could be a hilarious statement.
You know, if you were, if you're,
you know, being a silly person, just
joking around, she wasn't joking around,
she was bragging about all the finest
automobiles that her dog rides in God.
And it was just like,
what kind of nonsense conversation
would you have with this person?
That's the real issue with being single
as people don't want to be single.
You want to have someone that
you could spend time with.
But what are the odds of finding
someone who's actually fucking cool?
It's, it's, I mean I'm, I
met fucking a hundred uncool
people before I met someone.
Cool.
Of course.
And then it's also a matter of what
you bring out of that person and would,
that person brings out of you because you,
you'll behave completely different
in one relationship than another.
And why would they ship you
a totally different guy?
I was bad and all my relationships, but
he cheated. Fucking yelled never was.
I wasn't a good guy. I wasn't like,
I didn't listen, didn't give a shit.
And then when I met, my wife thinks just
changed for the better and I was like,
all right.
I remember thinking to myself,
I stayed single for a long
time and then I was like,
I'm the fucking problem in all
of these failed relationships.
I'm the Charlie Sheen like,
well to be a Bert Kreischer to be
the fucking party animal you, you,
you know you're going to crack a few eggs.
You got to Piss on a dining
room table every now and then.
Fucking shit's got to go.
Sometimes you got to rub off on the trains
and that's the only way you make it.
The Guy who's is funny,
as you are in this form of the podcast,
you know the stories is brilliant stories.
You have to, I mean they, you know,
you're funny on stage comes from years
of craft and working on writing and
performing and stuff, but
your, your ability to just
tell these fucking stories,
you know, on the podcast, that's why
you are created the way you're created.
That's why your life's
been so chaotic and insane.
It's to create this amazing product
because a diamond doesn't get made unless
you have a mountain pressing up against
a piece of coal and fucking smashing the
shit out of me for a million years.
That's how you make a fucking diamond.
You know you don't make a Bert
Kreischer was like a normal
childhood, no alcohol, no
drugs. And when they say,
do you want a shot? You say, no
thanks. I think I'm to get some sleep.
You know when somebody gives you a pill,
they give you two pillars.
You like at least gonna swallow.
One.
I cannot fucking bang with the guy I got
to take one. At least swallowing was,
man, you're not, you're not
completely fucking around here.
The best part about Johnny Knoxville
is I ran into him at California chicken
cafe one day,
like fucking five years later.
And I'm sitting there and he walks in.
He's obviously,
he's famous at the time he's been
doing, and he walks in, I go,
Johnny Knoxville, and he looks at me
Real Cretney real quick. And he goes,
Bert Kreischer, I went, shut the fuck up.
And he goes, the number one party animal,
the country. Oh, what the fuck are
you doing out here? And I was like,
is the fucking greatest guy?
And his whole fucking posse
was at California chicken
cafe. And I was like, oh,
I wonder if they'll invite me over
me. Them. I want to meet Steve. Oh,
that's awesome. Does he ever done
stand up? No. He's, he's a, he's, he's,
he could tell stories. Yeah. He
seems like he could do stand up.
He should do the podcast. Oh, it'd be
awesome. Steevo was fucking awesome.
That was he, why did he go in at
one dude, he was in the Ice House.
Chronicles number three I need to
subscribe to Tivo was, first of all,
he's cool as fuck. But second of
all, his fucking experiences, dude,
he was on a tree and I'll lie in,
climbed up the tree and got on time.
Saw that on TV.
And that was the craziest thing I've
ever seen in my fucking life. Dude.
I Tamed Lions.
But I saw that
you did what a damn lions for birth
to conquer did. Yeah, I was, no,
we shot it, but it never
aired. The show got canceled.
Like right after that we shot that,
the fight in the bear and then tailoring
the lions and then the show got
canceled. The guy tells me he goes,
how long ago was this? And this is
seven years ago,
I guess.
So 2004 video exist. Uh,
Mark Cronin as it somewhere.
I'm sure dude released that shit on
the Internet with fucking, it was,
it was a bizarre fucking
taming lions was a nicer you,
you have video of you
with a full grown lion,
like an actual three full grown lion.
Three full grown Lyons and
he brings them out of this.
I'm more crone and let's get
ahold of them. Yeah, I know. Mark,
do you have his phone number? Do
you ever, I know more gorilla.
He was my boss for like, he did produce
the x show on Fx. Love to see that video,
put that video.
He fighting the bear and getting fucking
raped by a bear and then meet him in
three lines. How much money do you
think, if that got a million hits,
how much money do you think that someone
would make if they had like those
youtube ads? I don't think I've
got a million hits. I don't know.
That's a really good question because I
heard that like Rebecca Black check that
girl that made that Friday, Friday
song that everybody's going to blu ray,
but it had like an
unbelievable number of views.
Like something like 35 million plus.
I mean what's the name?
You know who would know is,
what's his name? John? It's
totally no. Yeah, I don't think he's
going to tell you how much money's making.
Yeah, I wonder man, cause I would,
I would think that if you could
make getting millions of hits,
boy that's probably,
I mean to that video though,
Fox owns the rights stones
all asked them to do,
I asked him to do a DVD so it's like
them to release it and put an ad on it.
They can make some money.
Why not go?
Maybe it'd be worth it for
them to do it that way.
I'm just thinking like
how much for for you know,
how much does it like a million hits
pay in a youtube ad? I don't know.
I've never, I have no clue. And
it's interesting that that sort of,
you guys would have,
how much,
how many hits did you get on the mindset
of a democratic version of a television
channel? Really when you
think about it, I mean you,
you really not want to say democratic,
but an open version of it.
Cause it's like,
like there's guys like our friend from
the message board that d six Kid that
guys' videos have millions of hits,
right?
Doesn't mean millions, millions of
hits. And he's, he's got ads on those.
So I mean you gotta be making
a few dollars here and there.
I don't know how much it is,
but essentially like this is like
one step in a multistep process of,
you know, like exactly what
we're doing here. The podcast,
being able to make your own shit like
and not need a travel channel or a,
an NBC or anything to produce something
like it's so he could do it all through
the online and having it online is
actually like reaches more people than the
networks.
Cause eventually going to happen.
I mean how many times do you watch
something and I'm in full screen on your
laptop or on your uh,
desktop now, like a view to video and
you see it as like cool definition.
It's the first four episodes of Pan
Am on my computer and I was like,
watch Soto Margarita there.
There's a fight that's coming
up and they had that 24,
seven and I watched it on beach.
And you go to Hbo, go on your Ipad,
you can watch anything that's ever
been on HBO, anything for free.
Wow. I'm like, are you fucking kidding
me? I went down to watch the entire life,
all the fights while the fucking, all
the, what is 24, seven again, Hbo, Hbo Go.
You have to have, obviously you
have to have an HBO subscription,
but you ha you just log in.
We show it like it.
You can watch anything they ever bored
to death, entourage, fucking boardwalk,
empire soprano's, Kali specials,
every one's comedy specials,
anything that's on there, you
can watch it. And I'm like,
how the fuck is showtime not have that?
How does Cinemax not have that?
That was one of the greatest,
sure. Eventually they will just,
Hbo got there first and Hbo is on top
of that shit because I'll put that on my
iPad and go on the elliptical.
I know it sounds Kinda busy,
but go on the elliptical and which feels
better than running better on my knees.
Smart and he can go hard.
Man can go hard with the elliptical or
very casual and watch a board to do what
you do sometimes. So, uh, but men,
it's the best. It just streams live.
My daughters, this is how crazy this
has happened. My daughters, we have,
we have fucking more TV's in
our house than we could ever.
We have two in the man cave,
three in the, in the house.
And my daughter's sit in front of the
computer every morning and my wife's
little office and watch a Netflix.
They stream this live.
Next stage we need to set
up a podcast headquarters.
Let inside Bert Kreischer his man
cave. Let's do it. Let's do it.
I'm in for it. Brian. You
said it. I'm going to set it
up. He's too busy. Stop it.
You're going to have to get your
own guy and eat your own Brian.
But we'll set up just to
hang out at karaoke bars.
And Karaoke bars are a great place
to start. A lot of good sound guys.
Go to karaoke bars. Get A, um, a setup.
So you could just podcast anytime
you want. So you're sitting at home,
you hide in your man cave at one o'clock
in the morning and have a couple of
beers by yourself. You can
just start talking into a
microphone. Just ranting and,
and can, you can stream it live, right?
Sure. You can use treatment. Absolutely.
It's a beautiful qstream and you can
do it just like we're doing it here.
I'm doing it also goes to MP
three [inaudible] name it.
Let's name it Zune.
Did you say you're buying a Zune?
Is the MP three recorder Bro.
That's the one that Ari Irish
years and then I'm getting a,
and I got a good camera right now,
so I put up one shot.
What do we name it? Well, yeah,
that's exactly, I was going to say,
what do we call this thing? The machine
in the man cave. That's not bad.
That's not bad. Machine in the
man cave was not fucking bad,
but the only thing I would think of as
you would want people to be able to,
well what the fuck with Mark Marin?
I don't machine the man cave.
I don't know if I want people finding
Bert Kreischer because a lot of travel
channel's going to be fucking super
happy about me making another TV
outcast. You're not getting paid for
it. You're doing it for your fans.
You're doing it because
you're an entertaining
motherfucker and people want to
hear you talk all the time and
look what we're doing right now.
There's a lot of people right
now that are in their cars.
There's a lot of people at the gym.
There's a lot of people
that making some bumpy.
We're taking the train in and commuting
to New York, right back out the jersey.
Exactly.
And Boring as fuck.
It drives him nuts and you can
bring a little chill. I'm doing it.
I'm doing it like my man cave and I'm,
I am getting on this ship before I go
back on the road to Chicago. There you go.
I'm getting on this shit. I'm making it
happen. So the machine in his man cave,
I dunno,
I dunno.
But the travel channel is only going
to like it because it's only going to
promote your show more. Yeah.
You know, it's like, why
would it, why would it hurt?
It's not going to hurt bro.
Play. It's just like it on
Facebook. Yeah, Dude. Just,
yeah. Your online presence right now,
it's just starting to blossom. You know,
if you have your own podcast,
you'd be straight one and shit.
Bert Kreischer my right Brian.
Yeah, mother Fucker crusher.
I think you should just do it here though.
I don't think you should do it in your
man cave. Well, you could do it here,
you know, but yeah, but
Brian's, it's the easiest way.
I like to be a little buzzed
if I'm going to do it.
Sometimes that's what the
couch is for. Yeah, I know,
but what am I spend the night here. You
want to cuddle with Brian? Sorry girls.
Daddy's a death squad. I
can't make at home. How cool
that sentence sounds. Do it.
Daddy's a death squad.
That's the name of that watch to tell
everybody because people always ask,
what are these fucking squat?
Where does death squad name come from?
You guys call yourselves to death
squad. The sucker shoot over. Oop, oop.
From opie and Anthony,
I came into the studio and it
was with my friend Eddie Bravo.
No Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt. First
man to ever tackled first American ever.
Topic, Gracie and Tate,
Tate Fletcher, you know,
205 pound fighter from the ultimate, uh,
from the ultimate fighter. I was there,
Brian was there and he's
obviously a killer, so probably
have not. Yeah. And so,
you know, oop, looks at it. He goes, it's
Joe Rogan Brian the death squad. You know,
and we just started
joking around y'all bro,
with a dust squad like just as a goof.
And it became,
now it's like one of those words
like, like you hear it, you know,
you hear death squad and he'd go,
that is the douchey exist.
Most grow a dump,
but to us it doesn't even have
that same meaning anymore.
That's why the logo balances it
out. Yeah. The logo with the cat.
It's like when you're, it's like when
you and your friends just a name,
when you and your friends heard a
bunch of douchebags saying like, Bro,
Ham and spring break and then you started
calling each other bro him as a joke
and then all of a sudden you start
calling you up to other bro him for real.
Yeah. Like pro him. And he's like,
what's up bro? Im like, oh fuck no.
Are random white guys,
those random white guys I'm doing it.
Just squat sounds the
douchey best thing ever,
but it's just a a group of Nice people.
It's a group of Nice people
that want to make you laugh.
I don't know why that's a Douchey, douchey
name. Just sort of balances it out.
Otherwise we'd be two fe.
We'd be taken advantage of.
People would stomp all over us.
They wouldn't do it.
And Fierce Bert Kreischer people.
Firas Bert Kreischer does.
Any message you want to give to the
young people, the world. What is it?
What have you learned in your
time on this planet? My friend.
Just take half. Just take half. Yeah.
Don't want to Overdo it with drugs.
Just take one. Take half.
Just take one or two.
Take one. That's sound
advice. Sound advice.
My advice would be pretend you're taking
it, spit that bitch and the glass.
Wait a few hours to see if nobody dies.
People die.
But the problem is then when
you do take it, if nobody dies,
then unfortunately you're going to be
like last one to the party. You know,
you last one to the k hole.
Oh Man.
Everybody will be coming out
and you'll be sliding in.
Uh, one time, uh,
this is fucking right after college,
we go to a,
we go to a strip club, I'm living in New
York. We go to a strip mine, one boy,
he's getting married in Atlanta
and everyone gets ecstasy.
So we go to this with this bus,
this big fucking party bus,
and we're going to the strip clubs
in the hood and the swots. And uh,
it was just when outkast
came on with that song, uh,
everybody moved to the back of the bus
and they were playing it on repeat and
everyone took ecstasy and
everyone was taking it.
And they gave me one and I was
like, oh, I'm going to take it.
And then at the last minute I went,
I'm not going to take it.
I don't want to take, actually tonight,
I'm think I'm cool. And then 35 minutes,
everyone was started fucking going.
Flipper just passing out.
And I was like an where they were moving
bodies. I remember liber like going
like season, like yeah, having seizures
and they go fucking fall down. Whoa.
Just had an instinct to not take it.
I remember it was in the bathroom.
I had to be pulled and I was just like,
I don't want to take ACCC, man. I'm fine.
I'm, I was past that phase
in my life and I was like,
I'm not going to fucking take it.
I see.
But they've given it to me and I was like,
I have in my hand to that
kind of changed your life.
You got brain damage from that. Well, the,
all my friends now are fucking
stockbrokers and there I go. Well,
goddamn psychopaths,
they're always pots.
Both of the corruption that has led
to the downfall of this great economy.
Oh God dammit. Bert Kreischer. But
yeah, I did. I dodge that bullet.
Make a contribution to the world.
Bert Kreischer buy American cars.
You Buy American cars.
I have a Ford out there.
That's what I'm fucking talking
about. Brian Drugs. Shit,
I really would love to go all American.
What are you driving today? Um,
take out my BMW,
but you have a Ford Mustang.
That was my phone was my favorite car.
It's my most silly card,
but my favorite car. But next boss thing
I'm going to get is a hard top. The uh,
the,
the rag top freaks me out.
The fact that just fucking media
could just hit you in the head.
I went on hard type Dif.
Odds of that happening are very slim.
I just show it also feels like it's
about that, you know, I have a,
well, it'll lessen the blow. Perhaps
cigarette. He's Tom's a girl.
Put them on. All right. Oh,
took out of my fucking car. Hold on.
Why is your car on? Where's my Koran?
It's not a stretch ones.
Put It on speakerphone. I'm trying.
You want me to do it for you?
Hey,
you're on the Joe Rogan podcast with Joe.
Hey Daddy.
Tommy Burns.
When I talk about that guy Burt crushes,
you got a problem with that guy.
What did that, where are you at? Where are
you at? Do you bypass it ina come say hi
it right now. We're live right now.
How was the bird?
Christ and Tommy.
I'm going to tell him about the
time I shaved your underarms.
All right. I love you Dominique.
He, we were in, we were in Hawaii
doing a cake is under Tom's hair. Tom.
So fucking Harry. His hair connects
from his underarms to his chest.
And I was like, and I go, I saw, and
I go, Tom, you can't let that happen.
I'm so glad you brought this up because
I want you to tell me what you told me
last night. Is that cool? Can you tell
me last night what those guys said? Well,
the guy said about like the reason why
you were happy that Russell Peters wasn't
there when you guys were shooting guns.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Tell that story.
So let's, I'll start to
it for the, so we do me,
Tom and Russell Peters do a Gig for the,
for the USO,
for the military and Pearl Harbor, our
Buddy Charlie books. It flies us all down.
Russell's brothers' there.
Russell's a great guy.
Love Roslov Russell and I
love his brother even more.
If I could tick a one person to death,
it would be his brother.
His brother Clayton has got the best
giggle in the wine. Just get mad.
So think about it a little bit.
So we get there and Russel now
Russel is definitely a big,
like he's a big name and he doesn't,
he's not gonna he's there to do the show.
He's also there for vacation with his
check and his brother and his wife and
they're having a good time and
then when it's all to hang out,
but there's like a list of things
that they kind of wanted us to do.
One of them is like a sample firearms,
like go out and shoot firearms and and
like do this like thing where these
people come up in the,
in the screen and you've got to shoot him
and Russell don't want to do this shit.
So we're like, we're
like, all right to me Tom,
Charlie and all are wives
go out to do this. Like
simulation where it's, it's war.
We're all have guns.
We all have fucking,
there's a big thing up and
we get out there and we're
like, man, I wish I hustled.
Come. This is really cool.
And Tom's like, yeah, I know.
And then the guy comes up and he's like,
alright,
the simulation started in 30 seconds.
If it's brown and it moves,
you kill it.
And we were like,
well thank God Russell didn't come because
he would not have enjoyed this case.
That impression is amazing. Gimme
that impression again. All right,
this starts in 30 seconds.
If it's Brown and it moves you kill it.
God Damn,
that sounds like nick melting.
It's my old [inaudible] about 10
years ago is still robust. Oh. Oh Man.
I have a credit is the craziest shit ever.
So just so we joking around about killing
brown and then Brian and then Scott,
Tom and I just kind of blow it off.
We're like, oh, that was fucked up.
I'm glad Russell wasn't
here for that will Clayton,
cause they're both very brown.
So,
so then we go to do the show and I
go at first and I, and it's like,
I kind of do okay. Uh, but
I'm hosting a little bit.
Tom's younger at comedy at the time,
so he's going to go second because
it's a little easier of a spot.
He goes second, he opens
with a joke, like, uh,
they say don't make fun of Hawaiians.
Tom's opening joke was, wow,
island living is a really slow down
here. They, that's what they told me.
I didn't know they were talking
about your metabolism's. Wow,
these people are fat. Like that's
his opening joke, right? Yes. So, uh,
so then Russell goes on stage and Tom
and I realized for the first time we put
the dots together that these people had
been trained to kill Brown people and
they just have a brown person
headlining on stage and they don't see,
they're not seeing the nuances of Indian
versus Iraqi. They're just seeing brown.
And you can hear the murmur in the crowds.
It's like, why is this guy here? Why,
why don't we have a white guy
like you know, in their heads yet.
And Tom and I was just like, Ooh.
And then what about black guys?
Black is very different than
brown to, I mean I'm, look, I'm,
I'm also with the black guys having,
what are they saying?
We wish we had a black guy.
There weren't a lot of black
guys to be honest with you.
It was a lot of white guys. Yeah,
it was, I mean it was Pearl Harbor.
We weren't in like the thick of it.
It was a lot of officers.
It was the navy like,
I mean, and I'm also,
I'm also putting words in the mouths of
people who aren't allowed to talk right
now. So I don't want you to
think I'm, I'm from Pearl Harbor.
I don't have a problem with Brown
people. But I'm telling you, we were,
this was the heat of the war and this
is what me and Tom Experience. Yeah.
Know the truth. And it was,
and we were like, fucking,
then the next day they were like,
yeah, you're never coming back. Well,
and Charlie lost that Gig. It was a
really cool gig. Hawaii for like a week.
But so during this Gig,
so,
so you would go to Hawaii for a week
and do how many shows? He was one show,
two shows you used to do two shows,
one in like the mess hall for the guys
and that could be dirty as you want it to
do. And then one in, um,
and then one for like that
was on stage and like dog,
the bounty hunter would come
out and like wave to everybody.
So did they cancel it because
Russell was brown desc I think they,
I think they said they canceled
it because Tom and I were dirty,
but we weren't really dirty.
You know, like we were just,
we didn't like curse at all. But I
think they just, they just canceled it.
You can't curse. It was also a new,
you couldn't curse at all, but great.
But no one cares.
No one cares.
Could you imagine though,
the idea that you are,
they can send you to war,
they can arm you with guns and tell you
you're supposed to kill these people,
but you can't hear anybody
swear at a comedy show.
I mean that was the military. I think
that's pretty much like their thing.
They don't ever let people
curse on their shows.
I remember I read a Louis Ck article
that he had on his blog about, um,
going to,
uh,
overseas to entertain the troops and
about how one time he kind of got dirty at
a show and he apologized afterwards,
but he's just like, he couldn't help it.
They were loving it. They were just going
crazy and you know, he couldn't help it.
He just wanted to entertain them. He
wanted them to be laughing. But yeah,
I guess they, uh, they do
a lot of censorship, Huh?
Keep you from really doing your full act.
Right. But the first night there we
got, me and Tom get there and there's,
Russell is not there.
It's just me and Tom and our wives and
Tom and I did proceed to get fucking piss
drunk and on the beach. And then
we go up to his room. I don't know,
my wife falls asleep. It's
me, Tom and Christina push.
I call her in the in his room and Tom
has his shirt off and he's and his chest
hair connects from his armpits
to his tits. So you Tommy,
let me shot shape and that shape
that for you. I'll shape it.
So it looks like you have breasts so
you look more muscular and he goes,
you think that'll work? I'm like, yeah,
we're both really drunk. So I say align,
right?
I shave,
have a line here and I give him a very
well defined armpit hair that looks like
a fucking mustache.
And then it,
and then I shave all this and I just give
it what it looks like. It looks, yeah,
Tom got pictures and it looks like it's
tits wearing tits or wearing a mask
about to commit a robbery. This
looks like fucking two tents. One
Ooh, no one knows who we
are. I will. Well folks,
we need you to harass Thompson girl
on Twitter and tell him to put these
pictures online. We need to see these
pictures. He's got him. He posted on,
I think they're on his
Facebook to be honest with you.
Going to put down in your mom's house.
This was a great guy. He's really as well.
I love funniest fucking guys.
So did you want to talk about that
situation you had or know if five five
minutes perfect situation had yeah,
no,
I mean I don't, I'm not, I
mean, I don't know what his say.
I mean it's, you know, I
don't know. It's a weird,
you don't have to talk about it.
What do you, what would you say?
What would I say if I was you?
Well, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I, it's a, I don't know if I
saw Bieber at a grocery store,
I would also get hard on
that. Was that about, is that what you're
talking about? No, no, no, no. Listen,
I don't want to force you in anything,
so we'll just end this thing right here.
Uh, seriously. Cause we got to end anyway.
We got five minutes before the power
goes off because this is a three hour
podcasts already and that three hours you
stream cuts it off and then it becomes
two separate Hongson it gets annoying.
J Morton,
I've been very incestuous.
I would say with this Tracy Morgan story,
Jay as admittedly on his podcast,
said he,
her about that had
happened to him and he did.
He distinctly regrets having ever having
told it on opie and Anthony that had
happened to him. He started
telling it that it happened to me.
And at the time that he told her that it
happened about me, I didn't. I was like,
Oh fuck, that makes me
feel like whatever. I, it,
it was a story I never wanted told I
didn't want to told because I don't know
Tracy. I don't, I, I'm telling it's a
fucking something I never wanted to,
I want it to be behind the scenes. Like
when you have a good Mitch Hedberg story,
I thought it would be one
of those, you know, and uh,
and thought it'd be a good story that we
tell at comedy clubs and, right. Yeah.
Everywhere. Where there's a lot
of those a lot I like, yeah,
I got a great auto on George Story.
There's a,
there's a bunch of great stories
that we all tell each other.
And so Jay started telling us stage and
then started telling him that that had
happened to him. I talked to him on his
podcast about it and he distinctly said,
I'm, I'm done telling it. I'm
never going to tell it again.
I don't want to tell it anymore.
It's my wife thought it was a bad idea
the first time I told it. And then,
and then what happened was we went
to Amsterdam and Gary Finkel, Gert,
Gary Garfinkel, the VP of, of showtime,
said to me in front of a bunch of comics,
uh,
your Bert from the Tracy Morgan Story,
Jay tells on a special and which fucking,
it's like throwing a lunch meat in front
of lions. Like Dave. Everyone's like,
what do you mean, what
do you mean? And then I,
twofold protective of a friend,
I was concerned that he had taped it
for a special, and I was like, that's,
it's going to make, that's fucking
sociopathic. You can't do that.
But he, I talked to him today and
he said, you know, he did did,
he did tape it for a special, but he
told it that had happened to me, which I,
you know, it's a very, it's still a weird
middle ground because I, you know, I,
it's still your story. It's still your
life still. Your, it's still your story.
You told him the reason why it
was funny in the first place.
Cause you told him he laughed at it and
then he repeated what you said. Yeah.
And it's your story to the
events in, I mean, it's, you
know, whether it's, you know,
look, every story is not exactly
the events in category in,
you know, in order, in
absolute order. It's,
there's an art to telling a story and
that's what you're really good at.
You're really good at
not just telling stories,
but telling them what the economy of
words and setting them up correctly and,
and building it right to a big ending.
And that's what you did in that thing.
It's not just a story. Okay.
Because you didn't tell that
story as if, uh, you know,
it was, you're connecting the dots. Man
Walks on, land man finds plant management.
You didn't do that.
What you did is you told it
in a theatrical way and he
just simply repeated that,
okay, that's not telling someone's story.
That's stealing someone's bit. Yeah.
You know it all right Brian?
I think so.
Absolutely.
If I told you a story of
something that was really same,
I mean it's like that's a real story.
That's like I saw I was
going to stop doing,
I saw somebody get hit on the
highway and die. You know,
like the brain splattered out.
I talked about a long ass time ago on
a podcast and it was like one of the
biggest, craziest things
that's ever happened to me.
If I told that story to Joe and then
Joe started doing it originally as it
happened to him on stage to begin with,
immediately that would piss me off.
So fucking hard. And then the fact
that you've talked to them already,
I think that would even make
it even a thousand times worse.
I think that, I think that in this,
in this worst case scenario that I,
this is, you know, obviously, but
I think he didn't look his best.
He did that it the fact that the
story is structured in a funny way,
you know, you told him a story
that's structured in a funny way.
It's not simply a bunch of facts
just put together in a timeline.
You told it to them in a,
in an entertaining way.
You know, the, the, out of the, all of
this that happened, I think the best,
best of the worst case scenario is that
he did, he does tell it on a special,
I mean, I, you know, he does tell him on a
special that had happened to me. So in a,
in a weird way,
I get,
yeah, he gets the last for something
like, well, yeah, that's mean.
It's pretty important. I mean,
Jay, yeah. Well it's, I'm fucking,
he doesn't want to not do it because
it's too good. Yeah. He, uh, yeah.
And it's written out how you set it down.
It's not like he did not
put the words in the story.
You do only the only fair thing to do
is have Jay on the podcast and let him
tell his side of the story.
I don't know.
I mean or not or act like like like
exactly how we acted like that before.
We just don't fucking talk to the guys
don't have anything to do with that guy.
I don't want to be apart of,
I don't want to be a
part of, of the, of an
tack on Jay at all because I never,
I mean it's as much as I should
have been a fucking grown man.
I should been a grown man
at the very beginning.
If I wasn't comfortable with
what was being happened,
I should have been a grown man stood
up and said, I don't like this.
Make it stop right now.
That's what I should've done.
You're right. And in essence,
I, I didn't. And
so and so what is happening is
exactly you reap what you sow. I,
I allowed this behavior, I loud.
Whatever is happening to happen. It's,
and it's as much my fault
as it is anyone's guess.
You're in a bad relationship.
Yeah. You need a break up.
Yeah, I'll, that's what it
sounds like. Maybe it's to you.
Do you need to make up? Is that what's
going on? He kiss you on the belly.
Does he make you do things you don't
want to? Yeah. What does he do?
There's a secret here. You're,
you're your who were molested.
We're going to turn down the
lights and we run out of time. You,
Brian Chesky says yes.
It, we were at a time.
I don't want it just to
go over a good, uh, well,
we're over on iTunes,
but we have about seven minutes
on eastern being molested. No,
he's over on iTunes.
That,
that might work better than they
used terms. The thing that Tom,
Tom and I had a conversation
about it last night
and I, you know, it, it,
uh, it is behavior. If, if,
if in fact I should take a
responsibility for everything.
My Ego was inflamed the first time he
told it and he said that it happened to me
and my ego was inflamed and I loved
it because it made me feel good.
It made me feel like I was a real comic,
that I had a real fucking thing.
And then I thought that was where
it would end. I didn't, you know,
obviously we said this, I've said
this, Morgan feel about this.
I don't want fucking defined out because
here's the worst part is I never want
to trace it up. The reason I ever told
it, so I didn't want fucking Tracy to go.
Bert Kreischer why'd you tell that story?
Why do you mean,
why can't you keep that to yourself? Yeah.
You know, I have kids. I'm a, you know,
that's the fucking worst part
of it is. I mean, I think Tracy,
I doubt he remembers at night in the
slightest, but I don't know how he'd,
I don't know how he act.
It's hopefully, you know,
here's the worst part is I told it,
I told the story to a bunch of
comics in Cincinnati with Tony Woods.
Tony Woods was one of my good friends
who used to party all the time.
And Tony was there that night.
And Tony,
and I know when you tell the story
so much and then you start going,
how much of this is true?
Like you just end up getting,
hitting the beats of your story and then
you're like, yeah, you're like, what?
And so I said to Tony, I go, I'm going
to tell the story again. I go, man,
step in at any point and tell me where
I'm straying off from the exact truth.
And he was like, okay. Told
all whole story verbatim.
Antonio at the only point,
the correct it is.
He thought Tracy said more
before. He said, no, that's
how you get out of Panacek.
He thought that he was like, no, Tracy
stood up and he was like, check this yet,
and gave a little bit of a monologue,
which I just, I just got to the,
Oh say set a few more things. Like he
stood up and he was like, yeah, yeah.
And then, and then as we left, you
change that to like somebody else,
like Alan Thicke or something. It's your
story, Dude. It's your story, you know?
And that's disturbing, but
it's depressing isn't it? Yeah,
it was a great podcast.
I'm glad we ended on that.
Yeah, I had a great time
today, man. It was for him.
As much as it's important for you
to not let people step on you,
for him to not step on people.
Yeah.
He,
he knows.
I think he knows everything that he did
wrong in that trans transparent show
that you were a little bit weak
and I was weak and the and so,
so if anyone is at fault,
I'm as much of his fault and a little bit,
you let him step on you.
Yeah, and so it's completely,
it is something that if I want to
have a productive life as a comic,
I fucking pass it.
Maybe people hear that story and they go,
who the fuck's Bert Kreischer and they
researched me on is after a special,
I think that's going to do more damage
to him, then it's going to benefit him.
He's a great storyteller.
He's a funny,
really funny and he's a
great story story like that.
It makes him seem illegitimate.
It really, I mean he's, he's got,
he's better than that. It doesn't
need to do that. He does all,
his whole act is good.
He's a solid comic.
He's a very funny guy and it
doesn't need to do that one bit.
That one bit discredits him in a way
that's unfortunate and unnecessary and uh,
unfortunately really,
truly it's going to define it
smart is that big.
Killed then is the rest of his material.
He does a really fucking bananas.
Tracy Morgan repression is dynamite,
you know,
if you know it's almost excusable just
because of the Morgan impression is so
fucking good. It was a really fucking
good, when you read the chat threads on,
on Youtube, it's like he could
do that with anybody though. Man.
He does a great Colin Quinn and he's a
great impressionist. He's one of the best.
He is in my opinion,
one of the most underappreciated
impressionists amongst comedians down his
Collin Quinn
is on the fucking bun
and it's really funny.
He has like funny shit that he says,
no, no, no, no. I'm never going
to fucking man. You can't.
You can't not be honest.
You got to
breast the positives, the negatives,
the whole ball of wax. It's not
his, and he'd, he would agree. I would, I
would venture to say you would probably,
if he was sitting at this table agree
with everything we're saying to,
to a large point,
and I think his wife is Nikki is a lot
like you in the sense that the first time
he told that on opiate, Anthony has
it. It happened to him. She was like,
you fucked up. You can't do that. You
can't say that it happened to you.
You don't have to, you don't have
to. It's not necessarily, you know,
Mark Twain once said,
always tell the truth that way you don't
have to remember anything and it's a
smart fucking thing. It's a
smart way to be, you know,
people forgive you for the truth.
They don't forgive is horse shit
because then they the goddammit,
it's tough enough communicating with
people with noises that you make with your
fucking mouth. You know, that
we, we, you know, we would,
we attached to a bunch of meaning. It's,
it's difficult. It's difficult to do.
When I find out that you're making
artificial noises, you're faking it,
that you're saying things that aren't
true or you're bullshitting me or you know
you're,
you're representing yourself in any way
where I feel like now I can't get an
honest read from you.
Now our communication is all horse
shit because you just have this,
this impression that you want to put out.
You don't want me to know
the real you want to,
you want to put out this impression
and you wanted me to respond to it in a
positive way to fill up your
fucking insecurities. Okay.
And that's not what it's
supposed to be all about.
That's why when you were talking about
your machine story and you were saying,
could you imagine if that machines do
have somebody came up to you and goes,
dude, you go everywhere you go.
People, y'all at the machine.
I mean I have a tee shirt,
I have two of them that say the machine,
it has your face on it. Could you
imagine if that wasn't a real story
owed it would having a somebody else,
oh, it would fucking crush. Crush me.
If someone found out that that was a fun,
that it was entirely fabricated,
I would fucking, no one would ever
listen to a word. That's the only reason.
The only reason I,
I ever was hesitant about ever telling
the Tracy Morgan story in the first place
because all it took was Tracy Morgan,
one tine salmon that never happened.
And my entire credentials as a comic for
the rest of my life were done with no
matter if me and Tony Woods stood on
a soapbox and Washington square park,
like Charlie said, I just
agree and I think everybody
would believe you. Oh yeah,
maybe. Maybe. I don't know. You
know how people view Tracy Morgan?
Let's [inaudible] I remember,
I remember when I was young comic in New
York saying I had a story that was this.
It was,
it was based off of a bit that I had heard
in the music and I liked the way they
tag the song.
And I just wrote this bit with this story
involved and the tag was the song from
an outcast lyric and it was great.
It was fucking great.
And this fucking guy came
up to me and he goes,
that is one of the best stories I've
ever heard. It has it. It has ego,
it has everything that's
beautiful about a story.
You've got to tell me is it true?
And I looked at him and I
wanted credit and I went, no,
I fucking made it up and if you at me,
like I told him
I fucked Santa Claus, Santa Claus in
the ass, and I was like, I was like,
number one,
I will never fucking make up.
I will never make up like a fucking
fabricated. That is you just,
it just,
you just don't have anything to fucking
put your head on the end that you put
your head in the pillow and the
end of the night and you go,
all I got or whatever happened to me,
however I fucking tell it however
I craft it and present it.
Unless you tell a story that you
wrote and made up and then go,
I just made that up. That didn't really
happen. Oh yeah, I've done that before.
Plenty of times. Yeah. They're not doing
something for common book comic relief.
As long as you're not trying
to mislead people. Yeah,
as long as you're only doing it for
your intention is to fucking entertain.
That's what my job is. I'm a fucking
comedian. It's a fucking comedian.
He's a good one. God Damn.
And follow him on Twitter.
Bert Kreischer, B e, r, t,
e, k, r, e. I. S. C h, e.
R. Holla at your boy and follow
him online at Bert. Bert, Bert.
There's some sort of a sale today,
but apparently there's no fucking
just cyber Monday sale. And Bert,
Bert, Bert is not caught by his shirt.
I prefer the thin one. I have
both the Heather, your heads,
everyone rocks the Heather,
right?
It's very nice. It makes me feel
sexy. I like it. It's a light fit.
It's like a summary.
Breathe.
Thank you to the fleshlight
for sponsoring our podcast.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net and click
on the link for the flashlight entering
the code name, Rogan, you will get
15% off the number one sex toward men.
My favorite podcasts we've done so
far. Dude, you're the best. I love you.
My favorite one we've had, we also
sponsored by [inaudible] Dot Com o.N n,
I t today is Monday,
February 28th and it is cyber Monday,
25% off everything. When you put it in
the code, word cyber, other than that,
after today, enter in the Qa rogue
and get 10% off your Alpha brain.
Go get yourself some mood, knew mood. Get
your shit together, bitches. We love you.
We appreciate you.
We're all in this shit together.
We got a lot of more people this week. A
lot of mall. I want to do that live show.
Oh, we're going to have
Adam Curry too. Adam Curry,
you communicated to us through
your podcasts. We communicate back.
You are the man who created the podcast.
We would love to have you on. Oh, shut up.
Yeah. Hello. From MTV memory.
That's science. What it was
like to ferment TV. Yeah,
we've got Twitter. People are putting this
in motion. The real pod for of people.
I don't have your name.
Whoever you did this.
My one gentleman that I was communicating
with, but thank you, sir. All right,
I love you bitches.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Bye.
What.